Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. If you wake at midnight and hear a horse's feet, don't go drawing back the blinds or looking in the street. Then that asks no questions isn't told a lie. Watch the wall, my darling, when the gentlemen go by. Five and twenty ponies trotting through the dark. Brandy for the parson, backy for the clerk
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告干扰的音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。如果你在半夜醒来，听到马蹄声，千万不要拉开百叶窗，也不要张望街道。不问问题的人就不会被告知谎言。当绅士们经过时，看着墙，亲爱的。二十五匹小马踏过黑暗。白兰地给牧师，烟草给文书
Laces for a lady, letters for a spy And what's the wall, my darling? Well, gentlemen, go by If you make King George's men dressed in blue and red You'll be careful what you say And mindful what is said If they call you pretty mate and chuck you beneath the chin don't you tell where no one is nor yet where no one's been
给女士的蕾丝，给间谍的信件，亲爱的，墙是什么？好吧，绅士们，走过去吧。如果你遇到乔治国王穿蓝红军服的人，你要小心你说的话，并对所说的话保持警惕。如果他们叫你漂亮的伙伴并捏你的下巴，不要告诉任何人别人在哪里，也不要告诉任何人别人去过哪里
that is a chilling reading that was that was magnificent uh and and dominic we should uh we should explain to the listeners so that was about your sixth attempt. And you kept corpusing every time you began. That is a smuggler's... No, that was absolutely masterful. And that is a smuggler's song by Rudyard Kipling, a very moving and powerful poem about smuggling, Tom, which is our... And there's nothing funny about smuggling, is there?
那是一段令人不寒栗的朗读，那是，那是宏伟的，嗯，而且多米尼克，我们应该，我们应该向听众解释，所以那是你大约第六次尝试。而且你每次开始都在口误。那是走私犯的……不，那绝对是大师级的。那是鲁迪亚德·吉pling的《走私犯之歌》，一首关于走私的非常感人和有力的诗，汤姆，这就是我们的……走私没什么好笑的，对吧？
No. I don't know why you were laughing. People might think that I was laughing, but actually that's the distortion of the sound. It was moving, movingly and powerfully read as well. And yeah, wonderfully read. And today's subject is smuggling, the golden age of smuggling, the prehistory of smuggling, today's smuggling, the whole works. And the reason for that is that a very good friend of mine, Alex Preston, brilliant novelist, has a new novel out this week called Winchelsea.
不。我不知道你为什么笑。人们可能会以为我在笑，但实际上那是声音的失真。读得也很动人、很有力量。是的，读得太棒了。今天的主题是走私，走私的黄金时代，走私的前史，今天的走私，全部内容。原因在于我的好朋友亚历克斯·普雷斯顿，一位才华横溢的小说家，本周有一部新小说出版，名叫《温切尔西》。
And it's been greeted with rapturous reviews. And Dominic, do you want to know what a top critic, how a top critic described it? Was that you? Maybe. Go on. But only if you can do it in that excellent Rudyard Kipling smuggling voice. Imagine Daphne du Maurier crossed with Quentin Tarantino,
而且它受到了如潮的好评。多米尼克，你想知道顶级评论家是怎么评价它的吗？那是你吗？也许吧。说下去。但前提是你得用那种出色的鲁迪亚德·吉pling式走私腔调来读。想象一下达芙妮·杜穆里埃与昆汀·塔伦蒂诺的结合，
and you will have some idea of just what a thrilling, bloody and heady ride this novel is. Liam Neeson. No, that was me. Okay. Pretending to be a smuggler. So that was, it's a fantastic book. And Alex is joining us.
你就会对这部小说是多么惊悚、血腥和令人陶醉有一个概念。连姆·尼森。不，那是我。好吧。假装自己是个走私犯。所以，这是一本非常棒的书。亚历克斯加入了我们。
And Alex, that brilliant poem by Roger Kipling, you said just before we started that you can actually see Kipling's house, Bateman, from where you're sitting. Yeah, I mean, not quite, but it's just over the brow of the hill. So, you know, Dominic's rendition of it, you know, brought it even closer to home.
亚历克斯，吉pling那首精彩的诗，你刚才开始前说，你坐在那里实际上就能看到吉pling的房子，贝特曼。是的，我的意思是，不完全是，但它就在山脊的另一边。所以，你知道的，多米尼克的朗诵，你知道的，把它拉得更近了。
Of course it did. I imagine the ghost of Kipling is just over the hill there, smiling. Yeah, cheering. And Alex, so this is, you're on the Kent-Sussex border. I guess most people would think that the home of smuggling is Cornwall, not Kent and Sussex. And most people would be wrong. And, you know, I think it's quite interesting having a novelist on a history podcast, because actually one of the things that is most interesting about smugglers is how much is fabricated and how much comes to us filtered and distorted through novels. And so we think of smugglers being in Cornwall. We think of them very much in the mode of Kipling's sort of lovable rogues.
当然是的。我想吉pling的幽灵就在那山那边，微笑着。是的，欢呼。亚历克斯，所以你住在肯特-苏塞克斯边境。我想大多数人会认为走私的发源地是康沃尔，而不是肯特和苏塞克斯。而大多数人会大错特错。而且，你知道，我觉得让一位小说家来历史播客节目非常有意思，因为实际上关于走私犯最有趣的一点之一就是，有多少是被捏造的，有多少是通过小说过滤和扭曲后传到我们这里的。所以我们认为走私犯在康沃尔。我们非常倾向于吉pling那种可爱流氓的模式。
It's all absolute lies. And I hope that we can we can give the rest is history listeners a kind of unalloyed truth about about the history of smuggling. We like alloyed. We like alloyed. I can do both. So so that that's just before we get into the smuggling sort of the genuine history so our image of smuggling comes from what i would say moon fleet and jamaica inn is that is that right is that pretty much yeah moon fleet jamaica inn i would think paul dark um i think dr sin which is largely forgotten russell thorndyke which is they were set on the romney marshes so that was geographically much more uh much more accurate but um but you know daphne de moria is is responsible uh in the
这纯粹是谎言。我希望我们能向《历史的 rest》的听众提供关于走私历史的一种纯粹的真相。我们喜欢合金。我们喜欢合金。我两个都能做到。所以，在我们进入走私的正统历史之前，我们对走私的印象来自于我所说的《月亮舰队》和《牙买加客栈》，对吗？差不多是这样吗？是的，《月亮舰队》《牙买加客栈》，我会想到保罗·达克，还有罗素·汤姆。
in the large part for this moon fleet is set in in dorset um on chesil beach um and well alex we've got we've got a comment from kate wayne and indeed many others being forced to read and analyze at length moon fleet at gcse ruined smuggling for me so moon fleet is brilliant it's an absolutely Kate Wayne and indeed many others being forced to read and analyse at length Moonfleet at GCSE ruined smuggling for me. Sad about it, Moonfleet is brilliant. I think that that speaks very poorly to your correspondence literary taste because it's an absolute cast iron masterpiece. I love Moonfleet. Okay and Left of Centrist Dad. He's attacking the audience Tom, shocking. I know, that's punchy. Left of centrist dad, to what extent is our image of smugglers and smuggling entirely derived from fiction?
达克，我想还有大体上被遗忘的拉塞尔·托恩戴克，他们的故事发生在罗姆尼湿地上，所以从地理位置上来说要准确得多，但是……达芙妮·杜穆里埃在很大程度上要对此负责。《月亮舰队》的故事发生在多塞特郡的切瑟尔海滩，亚历克斯，我们收到了凯特·韦恩以及许多其他人的评论，说被迫在GCSE考试中精读和分析《月亮舰队》毁了我的走私兴趣。所以《月亮舰队》太棒了，绝对是一部凯特·韦恩以及许多其他人的评论，说被迫在GCSE考试中精读和分析《月亮舰队》毁了我的走私兴趣。感到遗憾的是，《月亮舰队》太棒了。我认为这很能说明你的通信文学品味很差，因为它绝对是一部无懈可击的杰作。我很喜欢《月亮舰队》。好了，还有“中左翼老爸”。他在攻击观众，汤姆，太震惊了。我知道，这很有冲击力。“中左翼老爸”问：我们对走私犯和走私的印象，在多大程度上完全来源于虚构？
I mean, basically, you've answered that. It is. I mean, it's hugely influenced, isn't it? It's very, very clearly influenced by fiction. I also think there is a kind of willful misunderstanding of the role of smuggler. And this is something we can get onto. But you have to think about when smugglers were absolutely at their apogee. It's the very beginning of the industrial age. It's also the beginning of a kind of centralised government. And so what you've got is localised communities who are suddenly feeling their lives managed from above, from away, from London. You have got this sense that they are losing some of
我的意思是，基本上，你已经回答了。确实是。我的意思是，受到的影响太大了，不是吗？很明显是受到虚构的影响。我也认为人们对走私犯的角色有一种刻意的误解。这是我们可以探讨的话题。但你必须考虑走私犯处于全盛期的时候。那是工业时代的最开始。这也是一种中央集权政府的开始。所以你拥有的是当地社区，他们突然感到自己的生活被来自上方、来自远方、来自伦敦的管理所左右。你有一种感觉，他们正在失去一些对他们来说珍贵的传统，而你拥有这些可爱的流氓，你拥有这些所谓的社会中坚力量，他们，你知道的，在向当权者竖中指。而且，你知道，这是一种当地人支持人们的感觉，这种，是的，他们游离于法律之外，但实际上，在这种情况下，法律本身就是个笨蛋。亚当·斯密在《国富论》中有一句精彩的名言。他说，走私犯是一个人，尽管他因触犯国家法律而无疑受到高度谴责，但往往无法触犯自然正义的法律，并且在各方面都将是一个极好的公民，如果不是国家的法律使那些自然从未打算如此的事情成为犯罪的话。是的，这非常像罗宾汉，
the traditions that are dear to them. And you have these lovable rogues, you have these kind of salts of the earth who are, you know, sticking two fingers up to the man. And, you know, this is, it's a sense of local people championing people, the kind of, yes, they're outside of the law, but actually, the law itself is an ass in this case. There's a lovely quote from Adam Smith in A Wealth of Nations. He says, a smuggler is a person who, though no doubt highly blameable for violating the laws of his country country is frequently incapable of violating those of natural justice and would have been in every respect an excellent citizen had not the laws of his country made that a crime which nature never meant to be so yes that's very robin hood
不是吗？确实非常像罗宾汉，但这也有一种感觉，你知道，这也就是为什么从地理位置上来说，我想考虑到你的家乡，你知道，我们知道他们来自全球各地，也许我们应该快速勾勒一下英国的海岸线，看看这一切在哪里发生，以及它发生在与人们认为它发生的地方相悖的地方。因此，走私犯的形象是一个康沃尔人，你知道，可能是一个康沃尔渔夫，他把这当作一种消遣，然后把他的不义之财在社区内散发，有点像在帮助瘸子和残疾人。但这并不在康沃尔。康沃尔只占其中的一小部分，当然就18世纪我们所谈论的有组织犯罪团伙而言。
isn't it it is very it is very robin hood but it is also a sense you know and this again is why geographically and i think thinking about your your from, you know, we know that they're all corners of the globe, maybe we should just paint a quick picture of the British coastline and where this is happening, and where this is happening in apposition to where people believe it's happening. So the image of the smuggler is of a Cornish, you know, probably a Cornish fisherman who does this as a kind of, as a kind of pastime and then disperses his, his ill-gotten gains within the community, sort of helping the, the lame and the halt. And it wasn't in Cornwall. Cornwall was only ever a very, very minor part of this, certainly in terms of organised criminal gangs, which is what we're talking about in the 18th century.
霍克赫斯特帮、梅菲尔德帮、西萨尔特公司，这些都是庞大的行动，拥有，你知道，数以千计的人。有点像黑手党？黑手党。我认为，嗯，我认为是有组织犯罪团伙，因为我希望我们接下来会谈到走私在今天所扮演的角色，这显然是非常不同的，但主要是人口贩运。我认为它们非常类似于今天安排人口走私的有组织犯罪团伙、有组织犯罪团伙网络。所以它们非常复杂。它们极其富有。西萨尔特公司的头目在大约1815年左右去世，他在遗嘱中留下了相当于5000万英镑的遗产。所以这些人确实非常非常富有。我住在
The Hawkehurst gang, the Mayfield gang, the Sea Salter Company, these were enormous operations with, you know, certainly thousands. Kind of like mafia? Mafia. I think, you know, well, I think organised criminal gangs, because I hope we'll come on to talk about the role that smuggling plays today, which is obviously very different, but which is largely human traffic. I would say that they are very similar to the kind of organised criminal gangs, the networks of organised criminal gangs that arrange people smuggling today. So they were very sophisticated. They were incredibly wealthy. The head of the sea salter company died in sort of 1815 or so, and he left in his will the equivalent of 50 million pounds. So these were people who were really very, very wealthy. I live
霍克赫斯特郊外。我认为该地区建造的最大的房子是西考克斯希思（Seacox Heath），由霍克赫斯特帮头目亚瑟·格雷建造。它太大了，以至于霍克赫斯特帮倒台后，没有人能负担得起维护费用。在他死后几年，它在一次保险诈骗中被烧毁了。所以听着，让我们把焦点放在英格兰东南海岸。我住的地方，在天气晴朗的时候可以看到法国。在多佛的最窄处，它不到20英里，从海岸到海岸20英里。你知道，确实有一种感觉，这里的风景只是刚刚与欧洲大陆分离。我想谈的一件事是五港同盟，在我的小说有声书里非常遺憾地被发音成了，
just outside of Hawkehurst. And the largest house I think ever built in the area was Seacox Heath, which was built by Arthur Gray, the head of the Hawkehurst gang. It was so huge that nobody after him, after the fall of the Hawkehurst gang, could afford to keep it up. And it was burnt down in an insurance fraud several years after his death. So listen, let's focus in on the southeast coast of England. So where I live, France is visible on a clear day. At the narrowest point at Dover, it's less than 20 miles, 20 miles from coast to coast. You know, there is a real sense that this is a landscape that has only just been separated from the continent. One of the things I want to talk about is the Sink Ports, very regrettably pronounced in the audiobook of my novel,
琴威港（Chinkway Ports）。他们没有扮演造王者。不，听到的时候我心碎了。但五港同盟真的很重要，因为它是南部海岸航海城市、航海城镇的一个合作社。它是中世纪的，对吧？是的。我的意思是，爱德华忏悔者时期就开始了。我想，我想快速读给你听。我拿到了五港同盟相关立法的最初草案。他们被允许免除税收和关税，享有索克和萨克（sock and sack）的权利，征收关税和金钱罚款，享有血罚豁免（blodwit）和逃亡豁免（fledwit），设木枷和囚车（pillory and tumbril），
the Chinkway Ports. They haven't played Kingmaker. No, it broke my heart when I heard it. But the Sink Ports is really important because it is a kind of cooperative of seafaring cities, seafaring towns on the south coast. It's medieval, isn't it? It's yeah. I mean, it's very so Edward the Confessor, it started. I wanted to I wanted to just quickly read you. I got the the initial draft of the of the legislation surrounding the sink ports. They were allowed exemption from tax and tollage, right of sock and sack, toll and teen, blodwit and fledwit, pillory and tumbril,
享有引进逃奴（infangentaheof）和引出逃奴（outfangentaheof）的权利、谋杀罚款（munderbry）、无主财物和迷失物（waifs and strays）、海难漂浮物（flotsam and jetsam）以及沉没物（lagan）。你确信那是1066年及相关事件，对吧？你可以想象奈杰尔·法拉奇（Nigel Farage）对木枷和囚车真正感到兴奋。但是，五个城镇：黑斯廷斯、新罗姆尼、海丝、多佛、三明治，两个古老的城市：赖伊和温切尔西。他们确实能够自我管理。
in fangenta hayoff and out fangenta hayoff, munderbry, waifs and strays, flotsam and jetsam and lagom. You're sure that's 1066 and all that, isn't it? You could imagine Nigel Farage really getting a head up about pillory and tumbril. But so, five towns, Hastings, New Romney, Hive, Dover, Sandwich, two ancient cities, Rye and Winchelsea. And they really were able to manage themselves.
他们有一个名为“兄弟会与吉斯特林”（Brotherhood and Gestling）的系统。这些是当地的一些名流，他们管理着货物的进口和出口。是的，他们向国王缴纳一些税款，但几百年来是有限的。你知道，这是一个几乎可以说是英国境内独立国家的地区。我认为如果你采取这种心态，我认为这绝对会延续到走私的早期。所以这是一种奇怪的来来往往。确实是。还有湿地。你又回到康沃尔口音了。
They had a system called the Brotherhood and Gestling. These were local sort of worthies who managed the importation, exportation of goods. They, yes, they paid some taxes to the king, but it was limited for several hundred years. You know, this was an area that was almost an independent state within Britain. And I think if you take that mindset, I think that absolutely flows through to the early days of smuggling. So it's kind of strange comings and goings. It is. And the marshes. You've gone back into your Cornish voice.
我的意思是，康沃尔口音和苏塞克斯口音有相似之处。是的，绝对有。康沃尔和苏塞克斯口音。但另一件真正需要首先确定的是，走私最初是一项出口业务。大卫·休谟曾说过，英国只有一个有价值的产业，那就是羊毛贸易。因此，英国羊毛闻名于世。如果你在意大利，你唯一想要的就是一件用英国羊毛制成的长袍。我觉得那穿起来会很热。是的，很扎人。但是英国羊毛，纤维的长度有一些特点，
I mean, there are similarities between the Cornish and the Sussex accent. Yeah, definitely. Cornish and the Sussex accent. But then the other thing to really, that I think to establish straight away is that smuggling was initially an export business. So David Hume said that Britain had only one industry of any value, and that was its wool trade. And so British wool was renowned throughout the world. If you were in Italy, the one thing you wanted was a gown made of British wool. It feels like it would be hot to me. Yeah, scratchy. But British wool, it was something about the length of the fibres
使其能够以欧洲大陆羊毛无法做到的方式进行织造。因此，第一项羊毛税是由长腿爱德华，即爱德华一世在1275年设立的。节目的另一个朋友，节目的另一个朋友在苏格兰，没有苏格兰公民，不，嗯，啊，好吧，那是我想弄清楚的事情。另一件真正需要确立的事情是，如果你想要一个走私的原因，那就是英国君主的挥霍无度和好战天性。所以基本上，他们将货物，特别是货物的进出口，视为支撑他们脆弱财政的一种方式。因此，长腿爱德华首先在威尔士发动战争，然后在，我猜是苏格兰，然后当然与法国，为了加斯科尼，我想，决定开始收取12.75英镑，每袋羊毛三英镑，12.98英镑，每袋羊毛六英镑。1300年，他们
that it was able to be woven in a way that continental wool wasn't. So the first wool tax was put in place by Edward Longshanks, Edward I in 1275. Another friend of the show another friend of the show in scott not with scottish citizens no well ah okay so that's something i want to get absolutely something i want to get at the other thing really to establish is that the reason for smuggling if you want one reason for it It is the profligacy and warfaring nature of the English monarchy. So basically, they saw goods and particularly the export and import of goods as a way of propping up their fragile finances. And so Longshanks wore firstly in Wales, then in, I guess, Scotland, and then with France, of course, over over Gascony, I think, decided to start charging £12.75, three pounds a bag of wool, £12.98, six pounds a bag. In 1300, they were
每年出口3万袋羊毛。自然地，特别考虑到英格兰最好的羊毛产地距离欧洲大陆有多近，这只会鼓励人们开始走私。所以如果你看看罗姆尼湿地，罗姆尼湿地的羔羊肉和罗姆尼湿地的羊毛仍然有点，你知道的，再次强调，非常出色，是最好的东西。它开始了，被称为“猫头鹰走私”（owling），因为像猫头鹰，背后有几种理论，所以走私犯被称为“猫头鹰人”，这是一个，猫头鹰贸易是，让……苦不堪言，就是晚上出去。嗯，通常人们认为这只是因为他们真的发不好“羊毛”（wool）这个词的音。
exporting 30,000 sacks of wool a year. And naturally, particularly given how close the best wool producing areas of England were to the continent, this just encouraged people to start smuggling it. So if you look at Romney Marsh, Romney Marsh lamb is and Romney Marsh wool still kind of, you know, again, brilliant, the best of the stuff. And it started, it was called owling so owling as in an owl and there are there are several theories behind so the smugglers were called owlers um and it was uh the owling trade was the was the bane of the lives of uh of exactly going out at night well it's potentially it's often thought that it's just that they couldn't really pronounce wool.
哦，非常像小熊维尼。是的。羊毛。我们迎来了节目的朋友，爱德华三世，1350年。他决定，实际上他不需要，他想要阻止这种事情，也就是基本上意大利和佛兰德斯对高价值羊毛织造拥有近乎垄断的地位。他说，听着，我们生产了所有这些羊毛。我想在这里建立
Oh, very Winnie the Pooh. Yeah. Wool. We come to friend of the show, Edward III, 1350. He decided that actually what he didn't, he wanted to stop this thing of, you know, basically Italy and Flanders had a near monopoly over high value weaving of wool. And he said, listen, we're producing all this wool. I want to create
我们自己的产业。因此，他鼓励大量熟练织工的移居或移民，特别是来自意大利的织工。然后他完全禁止了羊毛出口。所以这就是所有来到伦敦的佛兰德斯织工，他们会被殴打。完全正确，是的。所以他试图再次鼓励它。他没有做的是随后鼓励人们在他们到来时欢迎他们。所以这完全正确。当然，这导致的结果是，你几乎立刻就有三年的未售出羊毛 fleece 在码头上腐烂。
our own industry here. So he encouraged the emigration or the immigration of a large number of skilled weavers, particularly from Italy. And then he banned the export of wool entirely. And so that's all the Flanders weavers who come to London and they'll get beaten up. That's exactly, yes. So he was trying to, again, he encouraged it. What he didn't do was then encourage people to welcome them when they came. So that's exactly right. What it, of course, led to was you had almost immediately three years output of unsold fleeces rotting on the docks.
但当然，你也有人继续走私。此时几乎没有什么我们所知道的海关。执法非常非常不力。因此到了15世纪，你开始看到第一批执法的雏形，有点像我们所认为的海关服务。也就是税务官。啊，好吧，税务官是一个糟糕的词。不，不，但你完全说得对。这就是人们使用的词。
But you also, of course, had people continuing to smuggle. There was almost no customs as we know it at this point. It was very, very poorly enforced. And so by the 1400s, you start to get the first rudiments of enforcement, something like what we would think of as a customs service. So excise men. Ah, well, excise men is a terrible term. No, no, but you're absolutely right. It's what people use.
但当然，消费税（excise）是完全不同的东西。海关是针对货物的流动。消费税是在生产环节对某些高价值商品征收的税。实际上，再次考虑到为什么引入这些税，它是清教徒政府为了支付内战费用而引入的。所以直到1650年代，消费税才被引入。这里另一个真正重要的日期是1475年，船只上广泛采用前纵帆和后纵帆的 rigging
But of course, excise is something totally different. Customs is for the movement of goods. Excise is a tax at the point of production on certain high value goods. And it's actually introduced, again, thinking about why these taxes were introduced. It was introduced by the Puritan government to pay for the cost of the civil war. So that wasn't until the 1650s that excise was introduced. One other real sort of important date here is 1475, the real wide scale adoption of fore and aft rigging
直到那个日期，你真的只有方帆船，所以它们只能顺风航行。你突然有了这些船只，它们可以更加灵活，更能对改变方向做出反应，因为它们能够滑入小溪。尽管任何了解这个世界这一地区的人都会知道，这同样可以说是康沃尔的……抱歉。……发明。你知道，这是一个非常……
on boats. So until that date, you really only had square rigged boats, so they could only go really with the wind. You suddenly had these boats that could be much more nimble and much more able to react and change direction because they were able to glide up creeks. Although anyone who knows this part of the world will know that that is, again, something of a Cornish... Sorry. ...invention. You know, this is a very...
这些是长长的卵石海滩。你有坎伯沙滩，非常……坎伯沙滩是走私货物的伟大登陆点之一。你有邓杰内斯，又是长长的海滩，然后你有悬崖。所以通常他们会在退潮时在悬崖脚下登陆，然后用绞盘把货物吊到悬崖顶上。
These are long, shingle beaches. You've got camber sands, very... Camber sands, one of the great kind of landing places for smuggle goods. You've got Dungeness again, a long beach, and then you've got cliffs. So often they would land at the foot of cliffs at low tide and then derrick the goods up to the top of the cliffs.
但我们可以谈到这一点。在你继续之前，我有个问题。好的，请说。我知道我们说的一切都是错的。我不在乎。我还是要问我的问题。所以当我们想到走私，虚构中经典的康沃尔走私犯，对吧，他们显然是英国人，而且他们把东西带进来。
But we can get on to that. I've got a question before you continue. Yeah, sure. I know everything we say is wrong. I don't care. I'll ask my question anyway. So when we think about the smuggling, the classic Cornish smuggler, right, from fiction, they are obviously British and they're bringing stuff in.
你在中世纪谈论的是英国人把东西带出去。所以我的问题是，仅此而已吗？还是说也有法国人和佛兰德人在船上，他们想在他们那一头避开进口税，跨越海峡过来，然后带着东西回去？还是说这只是我们在包办一切？数量要少得多。所以这确实是一件非常英国化的事情。这部分是因为，首先，这是一个相对的，你知道的，英国的地理环境，我们是一个岛国的事实，使得这种税收非常有吸引力。此外，如果你想想，当然是佛兰德斯，你知道，后来的荷兰，他们在产品来源方面更多地向南和东南看。
What you're talking about in the medieval period is English people taking stuff out. So my question is, is that all it is? Or are there also French and Flemish people in boats who want to avoid import taxes, their end, who are coming to across the channel and then going back with the stuff? Or is it just us doing it all? Much lower numbers. So it really is a very British thing. And that's partly because, firstly, it was a relatively, you know, the geography of Britain, the fact that we're an island nation, it makes this sort of tax very attractive. Also, if you think about, you know, certainly Flanders, you know, the Holland as it became, they were much more looking south and southeast in terms of where their products were coming from.
我们总是忘记这一点，但当时英国是如此无足轻重。它在经济上毫无权力，毫无意义，你知道，真的没有变得重要。而且，如果我们想想为什么18世纪如此重要，那是因为，当然，我们成为了世界事务中的主要玩家，在许多情况下是一个稍微有些荒谬的玩家，但确实是一个主要玩家。而货物的价值是……你的数字是什么？好吧，我们可以继续谈詹金斯的耳朵战争。但是，这是一个真正关于非常贫困、非常乡村的情况，你知道，甚至一直持续到。所以在18世纪初，有80%的人口生活在城镇之外。大约有20%到25%的人口在申请济贫救济，也就是实际上生活在非常低的贫困线以下。所以这是一个非常非常贫困的地方。人们很绝望。亚历克斯，墨格夫中士（Sergeant Musgrave）有个问题。支持走私，我猜他指的是18世纪，但可以一直追溯到更早。在英国的一些地区，支持走私是一种社会抗议的形式吗？我觉得真正有趣的地方在于雅各布派起义时期。这是对当局竖中指的一种方式。所以，你知道，我确信我们会谈到的短篇事情之一就是拦劫船只。而且，你知道，如果我想起我第一次接触走私是在爱德华·阿迪佐尼（Edward Ardizzoni）的《蒂姆去灯塔》（Tim to the Lighthouse）里。
We always forget this, but Britain was so unimportant at this time. It was economically powerless, meaningless, you know, really didn't become important. And again, you know, if we think about why the 18th century is so important, it's because, of course, we become a major player in world affairs, a slightly ridiculous player in many cases, but a major player. And the value of goods is... What's your number? Well, we can go on to the war of Jenkins' ear. But, you know, this is a situation which is really about a very, very poor, very rural, you know, even right up. So at the start of the 18th century, you had 80% of the population lived outside of towns and cities. You had about 20% to 25% of the population was claiming parish relief, so effectively living below what was a
那是一本好书。难道不是一本好书吗？所有那些小蒂姆的书都绝对棒极了。它们太棒了。我读给我的孩子们听。我第一次给我儿子读《蒂姆去灯塔》时，眼里真的含着泪水。但它们太棒了。蒂姆的朋友金杰。
very low poverty line. So this was a very, very poor place. And people were desperate. Alex, a question from Sergeant Musgrave. Was supporting smuggling, I guess he's talking about the 18th century, but could push it all the way back. Was supporting smuggling a form of social protest in some areas of England? Now, where that I think is really interesting is when it comes to Jacobitism. It was a way of thumbing your nose to the authorities. So, you know, one of the short things I'm sure we'll get on to talk about was wrecking. And, you know, so if I think about where I first came across smuggling, it was in Tim to the Lighthouse by Edward Ardizzoni.
金杰服用了能让头发长出来的药水。当我被邀请到我儿子的学前班去读故事时，所有的家长，我选择了一本小蒂姆的书。那是蒂姆和金杰为了夏洛特的荣誉与几个粗暴的男孩打架的那一本，我想。是的，这是一本精彩的书。它传授了宝贵的经验。
That is a brilliant book. Isn't it a brilliant book? All those little Tim books are absolutely superb. They're wonderful. And I read them to my children. I actually had proper tears in my eyes the first time I read Tim to the Lighthouse to my son. But they are wonderful. Tim's friend Ginger.
我想老师们认为那是一个不恰当的阅读选择，因为故事以一场大混乱结束。哦，你应该读亚历山大大帝的。我应该……他们认为那是一个不恰当的阅读选择，因为故事以一场大混乱结束。哦，你应该读亚历山大大帝的。我应该这么做的。我本该这么做的。好吧，无论如何，抱歉，我们离题了。
Ginger takes the potion that makes his hair grow. When I was invited into my son's preschool to read a story, all the parents, I chose a little Tim book. It was one in which Tim and Ginger fought some rough boys for Charlotte's honour, I think. Yes, it's a wonderful book. It teaches valuable lessons.
不，但是《蒂姆去灯塔》。所以那里有一个走私帮，但他们是船只拦劫者。所以有这样一种形象，它总是关于移动灯光或隐藏灯光。这全都是完全虚假的。有一本非常棒的书叫作
I think the teachers thought it was an inappropriate choice of reading that matter because it ended with a massive fight. Oh, you should have read Alexander the Great. I should they thought it was an inappropriate choice of reading that matter because it ended with a massive fight. Oh, you should have read Alexander the Great. I should have done. I should have done. Well, anyway, sorry, we've gone off piste.
凯瑟琳·J·皮尔斯的《康沃尔的拦劫船只》（Cornish Wrecking），这本书彻底纠正了我的看法，因为我真的没有。我没有。我曾以为这种事在某些地方一定发生过，只是不多。但实际上几乎没有这种事情发生过的记录。而且我还想说，你打开这本书，上面写着“并未发生”。好吧，不。至少你在说康沃尔没有拦劫船只。康沃尔没有拦劫船只。我以前常去美国北卡罗来纳州一个叫纳格斯黑德（Nag's Head）的地方度假。据说那里之所以叫纳格斯黑德，是因为他们会在海滩上牵着一匹身上挂着灯的马走来走去，引诱船只撞向岩石。
No, but Tim to the Lighthouse. So there it's a smuggling gang, but they're wreckers. So there is this image of, and it's always about moving lights or hiding lighthouses. It's all totally false. There is a fantastic book called
然而，这显然完全是胡扯。不是真的。不是真的。一点也不是真的。所以拦劫船只真的没有发生。但事实是，我认为凯瑟琳·皮尔斯的书很好地确立了这一点，那些拥有船只的人以及为船只投保的人需要确保在那些会洗劫失事船只的人周围营造出一种真正恶劣、暴徒般的氛围。因此，虽然船只并没有被引诱撞向岩石，但每当有船只失事时——考虑到风暴和相对低水平的航海技术，这种情况经常发生——
Cornish Wrecking by Catherine J. Pearce, which absolutely put me straight on this because I really didn't. I didn't. I sort of presumed that it must have happened in some places, but just not very much. But there really is almost zero record of this happening ever. And I also want to say you open the book and it says didn't happen. Well, no. At least you're saying there's no wrecking in Cornwall. There is no wrecking in Cornwall. I used to take my summer holidays at a place called Nag's Head in North Carolina, in the States. And it was said that it was called Nag's Head because they would lead a horse with a light on it up and down the beach, tempting ships onto the rocks.
特别是在康沃尔，这种情况要多得多。当一艘船靠岸时，它就是公平的猎物。整个社会阶层从最高到最低的人都涌向海滩，他们把所有的东西都拿走了。但是亚历克斯，这种情况现在仍然在发生，对吧？多塞特郡曾经有一艘船失事，我想。是的，人们……那是12年前左右的事吗？上面全是洗衣机什么的，对吧？是的，我记得他们都去抢了，但不是。
And again, apparently complete rubbish. Not true. Not true. Not true at all. So wrecking really didn't happen. But what it was, and I think this is really established in Catherine Pearce's book very well, the people who owned the ships and also the people who insured the ships needed to make sure that there was a really kind of nasty, thuggish air around the people who would raid the wrecked ships. So whilst ships weren't tempted onto the rocks, every time a ship was shipwrecked, and that was very often given, you know, the storms, the relatively unsophisticated levels of marine technology,
那非常像一种狂欢节的氛围，除了船上的那些可怜人，如果他们试图抓住自己的货物不放，有时会被谋杀；所以每个人都会骑马赶到并抢劫这些船只。但是，破坏者的形象被创造出来，是为了将其塑造成一种社会不可接受的事情。现在，我认为走私者的形象正是它的镜像，他是一个潇洒、反建制的人物，就像罗宾汉一样，代表着一个游离于法律之外却又——正如亚当·史密斯所说——符合法律精神，或者至少是一个受到人们钦佩、并以牺牲外国人利益和伦敦利益为代价发家致富的当地人物。
you know, particularly, and again, this was much more in Cornwall. When a ship landed, it was fair game. The entire population came down from highest to lowest in the social scale and they took it all. But Alex, that still happens, doesn't it? There was a ship that got wrecked in Dorset, I think. Yeah, and people... Was that 12 years ago or something? It was full of washing machines or something like that yes i remember that they all caught but no
你打算说这不是真的吗？我的意思是，它们，绝对不是真的。好吧。因为，因为……汤姆，这里面绝对有一个主题。好吧，因为如果你，如果你真的看看苏塞克斯走私的全盛时期，这些都是，这些都是恶魔，那里曾是一片恐怖统治，霍克赫斯特帮。好吧，亚历克斯，我有一个问题要问你。我想我们应该休息一下。但我
it was very much a kind of uh a sort of fairground atmosphere um except for the poor people who were on the boat who were sometimes murdered uh if they tried to hang on to their to their goods so um everyone would ride down and and these ships. But it was created, the idea of the wrecker was created as an image to make this a kind of socially unacceptable thing. Now, I think the image of the smuggler is kind of the mirror of that, whereby it was a figure that was dashing and counter-establishment and was a representation like Robin Hood of somebody who was outside the law and yet, you know, as Adam Smith says, within the kind of spirit of the law, or certainly was a local figure that people could admire and who was making good at the expense of, you know, foreigners and London.
要把这个问题悬置起来。来自西蒙·吉尔德尔斯顿（Simon Girdleston）：臭名昭著的霍克赫斯特帮的历史是什么？这是你可以大力抽击到边界外的第一个半高球。当时的人们是如何看待他们的？是将他们视为浪漫的罗宾汉式人物，还是危险的、嗜血的罪犯？他们可能是最著名的走私帮派。所以我们要休息一下。当我们回来时，让我们谈谈霍克赫斯特帮。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的 rest》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一撮秀场八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告干扰的
And are you going to say that's not true? I mean, they were, it is absolutely not true. Okay. Because, because... There's definitely a theme here, Tom. Well, because if you, if you actually look at the heyday of smuggling in Sussex, these were, these were monsters and there was a reign of terror, the Hawkehurst gang. Okay, well, Alex, Alex, I've got a question for you. I think we should take a break. But I'm
收听、加赠剧集以及抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的 rest》。我们在与亚历克斯·普雷斯顿谈论走私。那个声音完全不合适，亚历克斯，因为正如你所说，没有任何利亚姆·尼森的模仿者参与走私活动；但你刚才正要回答一个关于霍克赫斯特帮的问题，我知道他们启发了你的小说《温切尔西》，我们要再次为它做个广告。谢谢你。
going to leave this question hanging. From Simon Girdleston, what is the history of the infamous Hawkehurst gang? So that's your first half volley that you can smack to the boundary. How were they perceived at the time as romantic Robin Hood figures or as dangerous and murderous criminals? And they are probably the most famous smuggling gang. So we'll take a break. And when we come back, let's talk about the Hawkers gang. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free
现在给我们讲讲霍克赫斯特帮吧。他们是谁？他们是罗宾汉式的人物，还是绝对的、彻头彻尾的恶棍？不，他们是彻头彻尾的恶魔。而且，你知道，让我们把镜头对准18世纪40年代的肯特和苏塞克斯，那是他们绝对
listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com That's therestisentertainment.com Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We're talking smuggling with alex preston that voice is totally inappropriate alex because as you said there were no uh liam neeson impersonators involved with smuggling whatsoever but you were about to answer a question about the hawkehurst gang who i know have inspired your novel when she'll see which we're just giving you another plug for. Bless you.
处于全盛期的时候。他们像管理一个私人领地一样经营这里。当时，你知道的，我们谈论的是一个海外战争的时代。也就是詹金斯的耳朵战争和奥地利王位继承战争。所以到了这个时候，英国已经富裕了。是的，因为我们向前跃进了。是的，我觉得我们，我觉得我们……我能快速填补几个空白吗？是的，因为我们向前跃进了。
So now tell us about the Hawkeyes gang. Who are they? Are they Robin Hood figures or are they absolute utter villains? No, they're total monsters. And, you know, let's zero in on the 1740s in Kent and Sussex, which was the time when they were absolutely
汤姆把我们向前 catapult（弹射）了大约两个世纪。是的，真是不好意思。因为我想把我们从走私是出口业务、仅仅是字面上的羊毛走私的那个时间点引出来。而且，你知道，到1600年，每年有12万袋羊毛被走私。海关服务当时已经
kind of at their apogee. They ran this as a kind of private fiefdom. There was, you know, so we're talking about a time when there were overseas wars. So Jenkins' Ear and War of Austrian Succession. So by this point, Britain is rich. Yeah, because we've leaped forward. Yeah, I feel like we've, I feel like we, can I just quickly fill in a couple of gaps? Yeah, because we've leaped forward. Tom catapulted us forward about two centuries. Yeah, I feel like we've... Can I just quickly fill in a couple of gaps? Yeah, because we've leaped forward.
开始运转。所以在沿海的主要港口，你有了海关。每个港口都有一个海关主计员和一个海关收税员。主计员（comptroller）。主计员和一个潮水监督员（tide waiter）——我很喜欢这个称呼，他们会登船并把船带进来。潮水监督员就像美国餐馆里那些奇怪的等级划分之一。无论如何，你有了，所以在1566年，“猫头鹰走私”（owling）要受到的惩罚是砍掉你的左手，并将其钉在一个公共场所展示。砍碎，我想砍碎更好。砍碎了之后钉起来就很难办了。所以1650年，我们讨论了消费税的引入，最初是对巧克力、咖啡、茶、啤酒、苹果酒、烈酒，然后是对盐、皮革和肥皂。
Tom catapulted us forward about two centuries. Yeah, sorry about that. Shamefully. Because I want to lead us from this point where smuggling is an export business, where it is just literally the smuggling of wool. And, you know, by 1600, there were 120,000 sacks of wool being smuggled annually. The customs service was by
所以，你知道，奢侈品开始被征税。而且，你知道，一旦这个消费税被引入，将货物走私到国内的行为就开始了。所以这是真正关键的时刻，船只仍然出海运送羊毛，但它们回来时满载着白兰地、杜松子酒、热那亚酒。本来我打算，如果我们是当面录制的话，我会坚持让你们两个都喝一杯Kopstut（一种热那亚杜松子酒配啤酒），也就是一杯热那亚酒后面跟着一扎啤酒。当然，蕾丝也是一种，而且不幸的是，茶。我觉得这有点不够性感，但茶绝对是走私得最多的东西。所以这是由消费税驱动的，
that stage up and running. So you had customs houses along the coast in kind of principal ports. You had, each of them had a controller of customs and a collector of customs. A comptroller. A comptroller and a tide waiter, which I like very much, who would board the ships and bring them in. Tide waiter is like one of those weird gradations they have in American restaurants. So anyway, you had, so by 1566, owling is punishable by having your left hand chopped up and pinned in a, chopped off and pinned up in a public place. Chopped up, I think chopped up was better. It would be hard to pin it up having chopped it up. So 1650, we talked about excise being introduced initially on chocolate, coffee, tea, beer, cider, spirits and then on salt, leather and soap.
而不是由海关驱动的，对吗？是由两者驱动的。所以既有海关关税，也有消费税。所以它是在偿还国债。它在偿还国债。它在为战争支付费用。所以它在为这些非常非常昂贵的国际战争支付费用。我们拥有了一个更大的国家，对吧？
So, you know, luxury goods began to be began to be taxed. And, you know, as soon as this this excise tax was introduced, the smuggling of goods into the country began. So that's the really crucial moment where suddenly the boats still go out carrying wool, but they come back laden with brandy, with gin, Genova. I was going to, you know, had we been doing this in person, I would have insisted that you both had a Kopstut, which is a Genova followed by a jug of ale. And of course, Lace was something that was, you know, and unfortunately, Tea. It's slightly unsexy, I think, but Tea was absolutely the most smuggled thing. And so this is driven by excise,
是的，完全正确。但是亚历克斯，这就像引入所得税来支付——所以克伦威尔或无论谁，你知道的，是的，引入了它——然后每一个后继政府都认为，嗯，这是一个赚钱的好方法，我们不会去——所以在王政复辟时期，有很多压力要求查理二世取缔消费税。
not by customs, right? It's driven by both. So there is a customs toll and an excise toll. So it's paying off the national debt. It's paying off the national debt. It's paying for the wars. So it's paying for these very, very costly international wars. We've got a bigger state, right?
相反，他建立了海关委员会。所以他说，不，我喜欢这个。它带来了巨额资金。让我们比以往更有力、更有效地去执行它。现在，当我们说“有力且有效”时，1690年，整个肯特郡只有8名骑警。他们的薪水低得令人发指，一年42英镑。而且骑警还得自掏腰包购买和维护自己的马匹。
Yeah, exactly. But Alex, is it like kind of income tax that it gets introduced to pay so cromwell or whoever you know the yeah introduce it and and then every successive government thinks well this is a great way to make money and we're not going to so there was a lot of there was a lot of pressure uh when the restoration came for for that for charles ii to outlaw the excise. And he instead established the Board of Customs. So he said, no, I like this. It's bringing a huge amount of money.
而且想必非常危险。危险得难以置信。对他们来说真正成问题的一点是，他们来自他们后来进行治安管理的那些社区。因此，他们面临着告发的压力——告发就是告密——告发那些是他们朋友、是他们家人的人。这些苏塞克斯和肯特的社区里每个人都在走私。所以通常他们只会收受贿赂。因此他们全都是惊人的腐败。整个海岸线只有300名陆上卫兵，21艘水上巡逻船。我们开始看到
Let's enforce it much more, much more sort of powerfully and effectively than we had. Now, when we say powerfully and effectively, 1690, there were eight riding officers in the whole of Kent. It was incredibly badly paid, £42 a year. And the riding officer also had to buy and pay for the upkeep of his own horse.
试图限制人们走私能力的法律的颁布或制定。现在，它仍然是一个相对小规模的。当我说小规模时，此时它还不是一个有组织的进程。这是由那些非常贫困的渔业社区完成的。这只是他们赚取一点外快的方式。所以他们可能会进行一次捕鱼航行。你出海捕鱼，然后顺便进去弄点蕾丝或茶。绝对是的，或者通常它是季节性的，与剪羊毛同步进行。所以你会把羊毛带到法国，然后带着茶回来，或者汤姆说——汤姆说——汤姆说“顺便进去”，我认为这引发了一个有趣的问题：他们从哪里弄到这些东西？
And presumably dangerous. Unbelievably dangerous. So one of the things that was really problematic for them is that they were from the communities that they then policed. And so the pressure on them either to peach on, so peach is to tell tales on, to peach on people who were their friends, who were their family, everyone smuggled in these Sussex and Kent communities. And so usually they would just take bribes. So they were all fantastically corrupt. There was a land guard of 300 men for the whole of the coast, a water guard of 21 vessels. We began to see the imposition of or the enactment of
因为汤姆的建议——我对此表示赞同——暗示了在另一端有某个人。基本上有供给也有需求，对吧？那么这段关系的另一端是什么？是的，这真的很有趣。所以它主要是法国和佛兰德斯。因此，基本上主要的贸易港口，对于苏塞克斯来说，是加来、滨海布洛涅、迪耶普和敦刻尔克。随着18世纪的发展，奥斯坦德也越来越多。
laws that tried to limit the ability of people to smuggle. Now, it was still a relatively small scale. When I say small scale, it was not an organised process at this point. It was done by these very poor fishing communities. It was just the way that they made a bit of extra dosh. So they might go on a fishing run. You go out fishing and then all just pop in and get some lace or tea absolutely yeah or usually it was it was seasonally and it was done with the shearing of the sheep so you would take the wall over to france and you would come back with tea or or tom said tom said tom said pop in and i think that that raises an interesting question where are they going to get this stuff
然后，当然，你还有罗斯科夫、勒阿弗尔和圣马洛。那是康沃尔的一端。但同样，我们可以说那是……然后他们是犯罪团伙吗，亚历克斯？还是他们只是商人？不，他们只是商人。所以这只是，你知道的，他们会在码头把一部分货物卖给走私犯。他们会把其余的货物合法进口。大概在这个时候，伦敦城变得越来越大，越来越富裕，而你在肯特和苏塞克斯拥有的是靠近伦敦的地理优势，
because that tom's suggestion, which I endorse, implies that there's somebody the other end. There's basically a supply as well as a demand, right? So what's the other end of that relationship? Yeah, that's really interesting. So it was largely France and Flanders. So it was basically the main trading ports, certainly for Sussex, were Calais, Boulogne, Dieppe and Dunkirk. You had Ostend, increasingly as the 18th century played out.
这是你在康沃尔所没有的。所以，即使你有从事这种行为的贫困渔夫，你也一定同时拥有某种有组织团伙，甚至……我不知道，某种冒险商人。
And then, of course, you had Roscoff and Le Havre and Saint-Malo. And that was the Cornish side of things. But again, we can say that that was... And then are they criminal gangs, Alex? Or are they just merchants? No, they're just merchants. So this is just, you know, they would sell a portion of their goods on the quayside to smugglers. They would sell the rest of their goods to be legally imported. Presumably at this time, the city of London is becoming larger and larger and wealthier and wealthier. And what you have in Kent and Sussex is proximity to London yeah in a way that you don't say in Cornwall so even if you have kind of poor fishermen who are doing this surely also you must be having kind of organized gangs or even um I don't know kind of merchant adventurers
然后，当然，还有罗斯科夫、勒阿弗尔和圣马洛。那是康沃尔这一边的情况。但同样，我们可以说那是……那么，阿历克斯，他们是犯罪团伙吗？还是只是商人？不，他们只是商人。所以这只是，你知道的，他们会把一部分货物在码头上卖给走私犯。他们会把其余的货物合法进口。据推测，在这个时候，伦敦城变得越来越大，越来越富有。而你在肯特和苏塞克斯看到的是靠近伦敦的地理优势，这是你在康沃尔看不到的，所以即使有一些靠这个谋生的贫穷渔民，你也一定会有那种有组织的团伙，甚至，我不知道，某种冒险商人。
it was initially absolutely the latter and then you know, the sort of the spark behind initially actually the Mayfield gang, who were the first real organised criminal smuggling gang, was was land was landfall so when they uh when they landed the goods because of course that you're relatively static and you're right you're visible um so that was the most dangerous part and then they would channel them you know remember that the landscape has changed totally since this time it, heavily wooded. All of this area, the Weald was a wild and totally lawless place. You know, you started to get toll roads built in the 1700s, but it was still, you know, people would take these trains of ponies up. And the reason the Mayfield gang and the Hawkehurst gang, the reason they were named after these inland places rather than being the Rye or the Winchelsea gang was because of this sense of being a staging post and a a management point on the road from the coast to London right okay yeah
最开始绝对是后者，然后，你知道的，最初推动这一切的幕后黑手其实是梅菲尔德帮，他们是第一个真正有组织的走私犯罪团伙，当时他们走私的关键在于登陆。当他们把货物运上岸时，由于你目标相对固定，而且显眼，所以那是危险性最高的部分。接着他们会把货物运走。记住，那时的地貌和现在完全不同，到处都是茂密的树林。韦尔德地区的这一带当时是一片荒凉、完全无法无天的地带。你知道，18世纪70年代开始修建收费公路，但依然有人赶着马群上路。梅菲尔德帮和霍克赫斯特帮之所以以这些内陆地方而不是以赖伊或温奇尔萨命名，就是因为它们是通往伦敦的海岸公路上的中转站和管理据点。
absolutely um because because there's a story isn't there was so much gin was smuggled in that people in Winchelsea would use it to wash to clean their windows yep absolutely and um and and also that so much cash went out whenever there was a uh a whenever a raid was landed because of course local people would be buying this stuff as well that whole towns would be would be emptied of uh of money that they would be you know unable to pay their bills for for weeks afterwards because they would have all bought so much brandy and tea so have we got have we got to the hawkers gang well i was just about to say before we get to the hawkers gang so what has really driven this to its apogee as it were are you've got to i'm trying to get my head around it there's you've got a bigger state which is trying to impose the tax burden is greater and greater presumably demand for luxury goods is
绝对是的，因为有这样一个传言，说当时走私的杜松子酒多到温奇尔萨的人用来洗窗户。没错，绝对是这样，而且每当有走私船靠岸进行突击运货时，都会有大量现金流出，因为当地人也会买这些东西。整个小镇的钱都会被掏空，以至于他们接连几周都付不起账单，因为他们都买了太多的白兰地和茶。那么，我们说到霍克斯帮了吗？我正要说呢，在我们讲到霍克斯帮之前，是什么真正把这种现象推向了鼎盛时期？我正在努力理清头绪：你有一个试图征税的国家，税收负担越来越重，对奢侈品的富人需求也随之增加，
greater uh for lace for for wine, for spirits, because people have more money, because you've got an increasingly urban population. So this stuff is finding its way to London. And presumably the supply is greater as well. More of the stuff's being produced on the continent, I guess, more lace. And of course, tobacco,
比如对蕾丝、葡萄酒、烈酒的需求都在增加，因为人们有了更多的钱，而且城市人口越来越多。所以这些东西开始流入伦敦。想必供应量也更大了，我猜欧洲大陆生产了更多商品，比如更多的蕾丝。当然还有烟草，
which didn't even exist before, or existed, certainly wasn't in the country before. And that suddenly. Same with tea, isn't it? Tobacco and tea. Absolutely. These are new things. The, you know, tax on tea was was 129 percent at one point. You know, this was that the taxes were extraordinary. And yet there was this incredible, you know, it was so voguish, it was so part of the way of life that absolutely it was, you know, it was all the things you said. I think maybe the one thing to add to that in terms of why it suddenly becomes this golden age of smuggling is the sense of a state that believes that the way to stamp out smuggling is by ratcheting up the pressure on the smugglers. And actually what that does is it organises them
以前甚至根本不存在，或者说以前肯定没有在这个国家出现过。然后它突然就出现了。茶也是一样，对吧？烟草和茶。绝对是的。这些都是新鲜事物。当时对茶的税率一度高达129%。你知道，这些税收极其惊人。然而，这种风气却令人难以置信，它如此深入人心，以至于它完全就像你们所说的那样。我想，关于为什么它突然成为走私的黄金时代，或许还应该补充一点，那就是人们感觉到，国家认为根除走私的方法是不断对走私者施加压力。而实际上，这样做产生的结果是让走私者变得更有组织，
and it makes them increasingly brutal. So when you say golden, I mean, you use the expression yourself, a golden age of smuggling. When we're talking about a golden age of smuggling, rather like we do a golden age of pirates, are we doing, I mean, is this the equivalent of people in the 25th century if they say, ah, the golden age of pirates are we doing i mean is this the equivalent of people in the 25th century if they say ah the golden age of people trafficking i mean are we basically doing that we're so the craze isn't it it's uh do you know what i think it is absolutely like uh
并且越来越残暴。所以当你提到黄金时代时，我的意思是，你自己也用了这个词——走私的黄金时代。当我们谈论走私的黄金时代，就像我们谈论海盗的黄金时代一样，我们的意思是——这难道相当于25世纪的人们说：“啊，海盗的黄金时代……”我们是在做这种事吗？我的意思是，这难道相当于25世纪的人们说：“啊，人口贩运的黄金时代……”我的意思是，我们基本上就是在做这种事？这是一种狂热，对吧？这是一种……你知道吗？我觉得这完全就像……
like the craze i think it is that same i mean i find the whole thing we should explain for for non-british listeners our 1960s London gangsters. Or Peaky Blinders. Yeah, I find the whole veneration of the Krays a really creepy thing because these were monsters. And the Hawkeyes gang absolutely were monsters. They would. So let me give you let me give you an example. So actually, the thing that really got me interested in this story, the thing that started me writing Winchelsea was, we moved down to this part of the world five or six years ago. And there's a there's a road I take on my way to the to the beach. And it's called Dumb Woman's Lane. And I, you know,
就像那种狂热，我觉得这完全一样。我的意思是，我觉得整件事……我们应该为非英国听众解释一下，这是我们20世纪60年代的伦敦黑帮。或者像《浴血黑帮》。是的，我觉得对克雷兄弟的这种崇拜非常诡异，因为他们都是恶魔。而霍克赫斯特帮绝对也是恶魔。他们会……所以让我给你们举个例子。实际上，让我对这个故事真正产生兴趣、促使我开始写《温奇尔萨》的原因是，我们五六年前搬到了世界上的这个地方。在我去海滩的路上有一条路，
as is the way of these things, I wanted to know why it was called that. And it was a lady who lived on the lane in the in the 1740s, peached on the on the Hawkehurst gang. So told the excise men that there was going to be a run that night. And they responded by by making sure she never peached again by by cutting out her tongue. So these were and you know, they were murderous. They were brutal. They they ran a proper protection racket as well. So if you think
正如这类事情的常态一样，我想知道它为什么叫这个名字。在18世纪40年代，有一位女士住在整条巷子里，她向官府告发了霍克赫斯特帮，也就是告诉税务官员那天晚上将有一场走私活动。他们的回应是确保她再也无法告发——割掉了她的舌头。所以这些人……你知道的，他们嗜杀成性，极其残暴。他们还经营着正经的保护伞敲诈勒索。所以如果你想想，
about, you know, where would they get their horses from? Well, of course, they'd get them from local farmers. And any farmers who would not give their horses for these runs would suddenly find that their crops had burnt, would suddenly find that their, you know, in some cases, their children were disappeared. I mean, this was absolutely horrifying. And yes, we can dress it up as sort of, you know, lovable roguery, but really in this case, it wasn't. It was vile and it was brutal and it was murderous.
你知道，他们的马是从哪里来的？当然是从当地农民那里抢来的。任何不愿把马借给他们进行走私活动的农民，都会突然发现自己的庄稼被烧毁，甚至在某些情况下，他们的孩子会失踪。我的意思是，这绝对是骇人听闻的。是的，我们可以把它包装成某种“可爱的流氓行为”，但实际上在这起案件中并非如此。它是卑劣的、残酷的、嗜血的。
And, you know, coming to the Hawkeyes gang, the list of things that they did to local revenue men. I mean, the very least you could hope for was being put on a boat for France and and disappeared. And, you know, if you showed your face again, then you would be killed. But many of them were murdered and murdered with the recognition and acceptance of what was a largely terrified local population. Tom, I wanted just to come back to one thing you said, which was about this idea of them being kind of countercultural figures. And I started talking about Jacobitism.
而且，说到霍克赫斯特帮，他们对付当地税收官员的种种恶行简直令人发指。最轻的惩罚也就是被塞进开往法国的船上，然后人间蒸发。如果你敢再露面，就会被杀掉。但他们中的许多人都被谋杀了，而且是在当地绝大多数惊恐万状的民众的默许和认可下被谋杀的。汤姆，我想回到你刚才说的一点，也就是关于他们某种程度上属于反文化人物的这种想法。我刚才提到了詹姆斯党起义。
And I think that's really an important part of this story. Because, of course, you have the first Jacobite rebellion in 1715, the second in 1745. And there's a brilliant paper by Paul Monod, Monod, M-O-N-O-D, called Dangerous Merchandise, who really says that the smugglers wouldn't have reached the stage they got to without the support of Jacobites. And, you know, there were these large landowning Jacobite families who would support them financially, who would give them places to hide, who would give them places to store goods. The Carroll family were a very, very powerful family
我认为这是这个故事中非常重要的一部分。因为，当然，你经历了1715年的第一次詹姆斯党起义，1745年的第二次。保罗·莫诺（Paul Monod，拼写为 M-O-N-O-D）写过一篇精彩的论文，题为《危险商品》，他在文中指出，如果没有詹姆斯党人的支持，走私者根本不可能达到后来的规模。而且，你知道，当时有一些拥有大量土地的詹姆斯党家族在经济上支持他们，为他们提供藏身之处，为他们提供存放货物的仓库。卡罗尔家族是一个势力非常非常强大的家族，
down in Sussex. And whenever the Hawkeyes gang needed to get rid of a body, it would be found, it would be drowned in one of the, or dumped in one of the Carroll's lakes. So when I said, you know, it sounds paramilitary. No, that's absolutely what it was. To a degree, it is a kind of insurgency as well as a criminal conspiracy. Yeah. And when you think about, so, you know, when you think about the sophistication, well, I guess at once the sophistication and the just the sheer violence of their operations, the sort of famous story. Well, you know, there are all these sorts of stories. But but the really famous story is that is the Poole Custom House, September 1747, a big shipment from the Hawkehurst gang that was being run into Christchurch Harbour in the West Country.
住在苏塞克斯郡。每当霍克赫斯特帮需要处理一具尸体时，人们总能在卡罗尔家族的某个湖泊里找到它、或者被淹死在那里、或者被抛尸湖中。所以当我刚才说听起来像准军事组织时，不，这绝对就是它的本质。从某种程度上说，它既是一场叛乱，也是一场犯罪阴谋。是的。当你想到他们的运作方式时——你知道，当你考虑到他们的精明程度，或者说，他们行动中的精明与纯粹的暴力——有一个著名的故事。好吧，你知道，有各种各样的这类故事。但真正著名的是1747年9月的普尔海关事件，当时霍克赫斯特帮的一大批走私货正运往西南部地区的基督城港。
So the Hawkehurst gang ran all the way along the coast. It was absolutely, you know, this was not just Kent and Sussex. When they were at their max, they were running the whole of the South Coast smuggling trade. It was taken by customs and all of the goods, tea and brandy, were stored in the customs house and the Hawkeyes gang just decided to go and take it back. And so they marched over there. And there was a naval man of war in the in the channel with its guns trained on the customs house. But unfortunately, the tide went out and the ship had to retreat and it couldn't it couldn't reach. They killed and captured tied up the the revenue officers who were in the house, took the tea, left the spirits, I guess,
所以霍克赫斯特帮沿着整个海岸线活动。绝对的，你知道，这不仅仅局限于肯特郡和苏塞克斯郡。当他们处于全盛时期时，他们控制了整个南海岸的走私贸易。这批货物被海关查获了，所有的货物——茶和白兰地——都存放在海关大楼里，而霍克赫斯特帮竟然决定去把它抢回来。于是他们浩浩荡荡地开过去。当时海峡里停着一艘海军军舰，船上的火炮正对准海关大楼。但不幸的是，刚好退潮了，军舰不得不后撤，够不到那里。他们杀死、俘虏并捆绑了海关大楼里的税收官员，拿走了茶，我猜他们把烈酒留下了，
well, probably drank most of the spirits, actually, because they were all roaring drunk and marched back. Marching through the New Forest, one of the gang, they were marching through Fording Bridge, which I don't, lovely place, one of the gang called Diamond, and they've all got brilliant names, Nasty Face and Diamond. Nasty Face. Yeah, Smoker and Poison. Yorkshire George. Terrifying. Yeah, terrifying. Anyway, Diamond recognised one of his mates in the crowd who were cheering them past as they
好吧，其实可能大部分烈酒都被他们喝光了，因为他们当时都烂醉如泥，然后列队返回。在穿过新森林时，其中一个帮派成员——他们正在穿过福丁布里奇，那是个可爱的地方——其中一个帮派成员名叫“钻石”，他们都有很棒的外号，比如“丑脸”和“钻石”。丑脸？是的，“烟鬼”和“毒药”。“约克郡乔治”。太吓人了。是的，太吓人了。不管怎样，“钻石”在欢呼他们经过的人群中认出了自己的一个老熟人，
went, you know, probably because they were, you know, again, in the sort of slightly criminal gang thing that they would have been punished had they not cheered them. And so he saw this friend called Daniel Charter or Daniel Chater in the crowd and threw him a bag of tea and said, all right, mate. Now, Diamond was later arrested and Chater was seized as somebody who was rumoured to know members of the gang and could identify Diamond as one of those who'd been on the Poole Customs House raid. And William Galley, an aged customs official, you know, I very much get the image that this was his last job before retirement. One last job. Yeah, he was about to settle down with the wife and the garden and it was all going to be peachy. And so he set out to the New Forest to get this Daniel Chater and to bring him to Chichester Court to stand, to bear witness against Diamond. And of course,
他们这么做可能是因为——同样地，在那种略带黑帮性质的氛围中，如果他们不欢呼就会受到惩罚。所以他在人群中看到了这个名叫丹尼尔·查特（Daniel Charter 或 Daniel Chater）的朋友，向他扔了一包茶，说：“行啦，伙计。”后来，“钻石”被捕了，而查特则被当作据传认识帮派成员、能指认“钻石”参与了普尔海关大楼袭击案的人而抓了起来。威廉·加利（William Galley）是一位年迈的海关官员，我脑海中深深地浮现出这样一幅画面：这大概是他退休前的最后一份工作。最后干一票。是的，他正准备和妻子安顿下来，享受园艺生活，一切本该是美好无比的。于是他出发前往新森林去抓捕这个丹尼尔·查特，带他去奇切斯特法庭出庭作证，指证“钻石”。当然，
the Hawkehurst gang, they marched and intercepted Gally and then went and rounded up Chater as well. They went to the White Hart Inn at Rowlands Castle. And Galley, poor guy, I mean, they were tortured and tortured and tortured. And it's one of these slight kind of knights who say knee things that you just cannot believe that they are still alive. There's one point where they're galloping horses up and down the beach with Chater and Gally underneath the horses, being both dragged along the ground and kicked in the head by the horses as they go. Anyway, Gally buried alive, Chater thrown in a well, dead as well. So Alex, I mean...
霍克赫斯特帮一路追踪并截住了加利，随后又把查特也抓了起来。他们去了罗兰兹城堡的白鹿客栈。加利，这个可怜的家伙，我的意思是，他们经受了一轮又一轮极其残酷的虐待。这就像那种让你简直不敢相信他们居然还活着的骇人听闻的虐待。有一次，他们骑着马在海滩上狂奔，把查特和加利绑在马腹下方，在地上活活拖行，途中还不断遭到马蹄的踢踹。总之，加利被活埋，查特也被扔进井里，同样惨死。所以，亚历克斯，我的意思是……
It's not Captain Pugwash, is it? It is not Captain Pugwash, who it? It is not Captain Pugwash, who, by the way, was also drawn by somebody from Rye. Was he? Ah, well, everything does connect. I mean, so all this stuff is going on. Surely there must be some kind of kickback. From local people.
这不是“胖戈士船长”（Captain Pugwash），对吧？这当然不是胖戈士船长。顺便说一句，胖戈士船长也是由一个来自赖伊的人画的。是吗？啊，好吧，万物皆有联系。我的意思是，既然所有这些事情都在发生，那就肯定会遭到某种反弹。来自当地人的反弹。
Well, or from the state. Yeah, from the state. So, absolutely. So, 1736, the Act of Indemnity. Now, this was major. So, 1736, the act of indemnity. Now this was major. So 1736, act of indemnity, what this said was that you basically got off scot-free if you told the authorities about a run that was going to happen. But that only works if you've got some kind of witness protection. Well, that is the problem that you unfortunately don't have. You know, again, while this is going on, there are foreign wars.
好吧，或者来自国家。是的，来自国家。所以，当然。1736年，《豁免法案》。这可是个大事。所以，1736年的《豁免法案》……现在这可是个大事件。所以1736年的《豁免法案》，其内容是：如果你向当局举报即将发生的走私活动，你基本上就可以逃脱法律制裁。但前提是你得有某种证人保护。嗯，问题就在于，你偏偏没有这种保护。你知道，同样地，在这一切发生的期间，还有着对外战争。
There really isn't enough money being put into this. You've got 1739, the War of Jenkins here. 1746, they up the ante again, the authorities. There is very clear evidence at this time that the government were recognising that the only real answer here was to lower taxes. And Pelham lowered taxes in several times in the 1740s, but then always had something else to pay for. Pelham, the prime minister at the time, always had something else to pay for. And so would have to raise taxes again. 1746, the Gazetting Act. So So the Gazeting Act was that the name of suspected smugglers was listed in the London Gazette, and you had 40 days to turn yourself in. And if you
政府确实没有投入足够的资金来解决这个问题。你经历了1739年的詹金斯耳朵之战。1746年，当局再次加码。当时有非常清晰的证据表明，政府已经意识到，解决这个问题的唯一真正办法是减税。佩勒姆在18世纪40年代曾多次减税，但随后总有别的花销需要应付。当时的首相佩勒姆总是需要钱去支付其他开支，因此不得不再次加税。1746年，《公报法案》。所以，所谓的《公报法案》就是把涉嫌走私者的名字刊登在《伦敦公报》上，给你40天的时间自首。如果你
didn't, you would be, a bounty would be put on your head, 500 pounds. Now, to give an idea of what that was, you know, a day labourer would earn about seven pence a day. So this was major cash. They also imposed the death penalty. So it was already, you know, being a smuggler was punishable with death. You were penalised. So death penalty for wearing a wizard's mask, which, you know, which of us wouldn't be hit with that now? Wearing a wizard's mask. Is this still on the statute book? I hope so. So hovering within six miles of land. Hovering?
不这么做，你的头上就会被悬赏，赏金高达500英镑。为了让大家对这个金额有个概念：一个日薪劳工一天大约只能赚七便士。所以这是一大笔钱。他们还强力推行了死刑。当时走私本身就已经会被判处死刑了。你受到了惩罚。因此，戴着巫师面具也要被判死刑——你知道，现在我们当中有谁能逃过这一条呢？戴着巫师面具。这条法律现在还在成文法典里吗？我希望还在。还有，在离岸六英里范围内徘徊。徘徊？
Yes. So hovering, that is to say. Really harsh on the wizards. Really harsh on the wizards. Yeah, imagine if you were wearing your mask and hovering. So that is to say, if your ship was offshore, because of course they would wait wait for signaling to come in. And we can maybe talk about how a run was actually arranged because it was a fairly intricate series of signals. And then a death penalty even for being seen in the area of smuggling gangs.
是的。所以徘徊，也就是……对巫师太严厉了。对巫师太严厉了。是的，想象一下如果你戴着面具还在那里徘徊。也就是说，如果你的船停在离岸不远的地方——因为他们当然要等待信号传过来。我们也许可以聊聊一次走私行动实际上是如何安排的，因为那是一系列相当复杂的信号。然后，甚至只要被发现在走私团伙的活动区域出没，就会被判处死刑。
So they were really trying to ratchet this up. Does it work? Yeah, I think that is what finally works. Alongside a real public upswell of disgust and, you know, just having had enough. Because the climax of your book, am I allowed to say this? Yeah, definitely. Of course, it's historically accurate. There is this kind of high noon type showdown in a village called Goodhurst. Goudhurst, yeah. Goudhurst, yeah.
所以他们真的在拼命加码。这管用吗？是的，我认为这最终起到了作用。与此同时，公众的厌恶情绪高涨，大家真的是忍无可忍了。因为这是你书中的高潮部分，我能说这个吗？可以，当然可以。这绝对符合历史事实。在古德赫斯特这个村庄里，有一场类似正午决斗的对峙。古德赫斯特（Goudhurst），是的。古德赫斯特，是的。
Goudhurst, sorry. So just tell us about that because it's a very dramatic episode that seems barely credible when you go through rural Sussex. It's a great village, actually. We looked at a house there that had a smuggler's tunnel over to the church that was really exciting that I sort of wish we'd bought it. But no, so Battle of Goudhurst. With your wizard's mask.
古德赫斯特，抱歉。给我们讲讲那个故事吧，因为那是一个非常戏剧性的情节，当你穿行于苏塞克斯乡村时，它简直让人难以置信。那其实是个很棒的村庄。我们在那里看中过一栋房子，里面有一条通往教堂的走私犯地道，非常令人兴奋，我当时甚至希望我们把它买下来。不过说回古德赫斯特战役……你戴着巫师的面具。
Yes, exactly. Battle of Goudhurst. Yes, exactly. Battle of Goudhurst, 21st of April, 1747. It's a wonderful story because it was, again, the Hawkehurst gang reign of terror. Tom, you'll like this. They murdered someone during a cricket match on Horseman and Green. What?
没错，正是如此。古德赫斯特战役，1747年4月21日。这是一个精彩的故事，因为当时——又是霍克赫斯特帮的恐怖统治。汤姆，你会喜欢这个的。他们在霍斯曼格林的一场板球比赛中谋杀了一个人。什么？
So yeah, actually marched out into the middle and murdered him in front of his teammates. I mean, Tom, I would not let that happen to you. No, I do not. Are you his captain? I'm not his captain. No, I'm not really captain material. Okay.
所以，是的，他们实际上大摇大摆地走到球场中央，在队友面前谋杀了这个人。汤姆，我可绝不会让你落得那种下场。不，我不会的。你是他的队长吗？我不是他的队长。不，我真不是当长官的料。好吧。
Tom's not captain, is he? No, no, he's not. He's even less captain material. No, Charlie, I was a captain for years. Were you of that team, the authors cricket team? No, I ran a team for 20 years and then uh various people in that team went off and founded another one i i am i'm kind of like rome to the constantinople that is the authors right yeah that's not quite the analogy i was anyway they murdered they murdered
汤姆不是队长，对吧？不，不，他不是。他更不可能是当队长的料。不，查理，我当过好几年的队长。你是那个球队的队长吗？作者板球队？不，我经营了一支球队20年，然后该队的各种成员离开并创立了另一支球队。我……我有点像罗马面对君士坦丁堡那样，也就是那些作家，对吧？这比喻不太贴切。不管怎样，他们谋杀……
so they were and and you know rape and pillage um lock up your daughters etc it was really really horrifying so the people of goudhurst decided they'd had enough. And it was under the aegis of this very mysterious figure called William Sturt. He was an ex-soldier, retired after his soldiering to Goudhurst, and founded what he called the Goudhurst Militia, of which my great, great, great, great, great, great grandfather, George Kent, was a member. It was initially to protect their crops and their livestock and their families from the Hawkehurst gang. But George Kingsmill, so the two leading figures of the Hawkehurst gang, three leading figures, the
所以他们当时就是这样——烧杀抢掠，把你的女儿们锁好等等，这真的、真的太骇人听闻了。所以古德赫斯特的人民决定忍无可忍了。这一切是在一个名叫威廉·斯图尔特（William Sturt）的神秘人物的领导下进行的。他是一名退伍军人，退役后在古德赫斯特定居，并组建了他所谓的“古德赫斯特民兵组织”，我的玄祖父乔治·肯特（George Kent）就是其中一员。最初成立这个组织的目的是为了保护他们的庄稼、牲畜和家人免受霍克赫斯特帮的侵害。但是乔治·金斯米尔（George Kingsmill）——霍克赫斯特帮的两个主要头目、三个主要头目：
Kingsmill brothers, Thomas and George Kingsmill, and Arthur Gray, who was this kind of foppish esthete from Rye. The Kingsmill brothers were real sort of, you know, they had hands like hams and faces like hams, and they were basically hams. What are they doing hanging around with this fop then? Was he there for window dressing? I think he handled the continental negotiations and they did the duffing up. But anyway, so... Is Id driselba in the wire yeah you know i mean this is so the way it is the wire meets
金斯米尔兄弟，托马斯和乔治·金斯米尔，以及亚瑟·格雷（Arthur Gray），一个来自赖伊的、装腔作势的唯美主义者。金斯米尔兄弟简直就是那种……他们的手长得像火腿，脸也长得像火腿，他们根本就是火腿。那他们怎么会跟这个花花公子混在一起呢？他是去撑门面的吗？我想他负责处理欧洲大陆的谈判，而他们负责动手打人。不管怎样……这简直就是《火线》里的桥段，真的，你知道吗？这简直就是《火线》和《波尔达克》在这里的结合，老实说……所以这就像《迪比莱牧师》一样，这正是它的有趣之处。是的，这确实有趣。所以他听说这个民兵组织已经成立了，但他们还没有与霍克赫斯特帮正面交锋。
poldark down here honestly um so he makes the vicar of dibbly and that's the fun of it yeah that is the fun of it so he heard that this militia had been set up uh they had yet to to meet the the hawkehurst gang face on. And he marched into the church on a Sunday and said, disband or I'll wring your livers out. He's got a Cornish accent, too. He does have a Cornish accent, too. And so the militia got together and they said, well, we can either stand up to these people or we can continue to have our lives ruled by these ruffians.
于是他在一个星期天大摇大摆地走进教堂，说道：“解散，否则我掏出你们的肝脏。”他说话还带点康沃尔口音呢。他确实也带点康沃尔口音。于是民兵们聚在一起商量，他们说：“要么我们站出来跟这些人对抗，要么我们就继续让我们的生活被这群暴徒统治。”
And William Sturt apparently gave a very moving speech and said, no, we're going to fight them. And so the gang, they sent their message back. They said, we will not disband. And the gang said, right, we're coming for you tomorrow. And so they got together. They sent all of the women, children and elderly out of the town. They got fouling pieces, pitchforks. They heaped up, went down to Battle, which is just nearby, which was the centre of ammunition. And they bought one cannon.
据说威廉·斯图尔特发表了一场非常感人的演讲，说：“不，我们要跟他们战斗。”于是民兵组织回信了。他们说：“我们绝不解散。”而帮派则回应道：“好，我们明天就去找你们算账。”于是他们聚集起来。他们把所有的妇女、儿童和老人送出了镇子。他们准备了猎鸟枪、草叉。他们堆起防御工事，去了附近的“战役村”（Battle）——那是弹药中心，在那里买了一门大炮。
They got a cannon? Yeah, placed it on the church ramparts. There were 25 of them and only Sturt had ever seen had ever seen action before in. But he had drilled them incredibly well. And the church, if you see it, has got this very crenellated top. I mean, it's almost made for it. They stacked up a kind of barricades of gravestones around them. 400 of the Hawkehurst gang arrived against 25 of these guys. This is dramatic. It's Rourke's Drift.
他们弄到了一门大炮？是的，把它架在教堂的胸墙上。他们总共有25个人，其中只有斯图尔特有过实战经验。但他把民兵们训练得极为出色。如果你去看看那座教堂，它有着非常锯齿状的雉堞屋顶。我的意思是，它简直就是为这种战斗而生的。他们在周围用墓碑堆起了防御工事。面对这25个人，霍克赫斯特帮来了400人。这太戏剧性了。简直就是罗克渡口之战（Rourke's Drift）。
They had been up drinking at Arthur Gray's. It was called Gray's Folly, Seacock's Heath, this enormous house just outside of Hawkehurst. They'd been up drinking all night. They were rolling drunk. They had daubed their bodies with paint. And they were, they were right, many of them riding on horseback, incredibly well armed, armed to the teeth. And the battle started. And it was suddenly seen that the, the, the Goudhurst militia just had this wonderful tactical advantage of A, being not
他们一直在亚瑟·格雷的住所喝酒。那个地方叫格雷的愚蠢庄园（Gray's Folly）、西科克斯希思（Seacock's Heath），是霍克赫斯特郊外的一座巨大宅邸。他们通宵狂饮，烂醉如泥。他们在身上涂满了颜料。他们——没错，他们许多人骑着马，全副武装，武装到牙齿。战斗打响了。人们突然发现，古德赫斯特民兵占据了绝佳的战术优势：第一，他们没有烂醉如泥；第二，他们占据了地势优势，因为教堂本来就在山坡上，而且他们占据了高处。
totally drunk, and B, being on this eminence, because the church is up on a hill anyway, and they were raised. And so they didn't lose a single life from the militia. They killed many of the gang. And then just as the battle was kind of poised to go one way or another, the dragoons turned up at the back of the gang, the gang scattered, Kingsmill and Gray were captured and were executed. And that was the end of the Hawkehurst gang. And really, it was the end of that kind of official smuggling. There were more gangs that it definitely kind of ebbed and flowed. But in terms of as we, you know, inverted commas, the golden age, that was it. So Alex, you have your hero, heroine is a woman. How many women were involved in this? Because there were a few, weren't there? There were a few, but it's also not something, I mean,
因此，民兵方面没有一人伤亡。他们击毙了帮派中的许多人。就在战斗呈胶着状态、胜负难料之际，龙骑兵从帮派的后方杀了出来。帮派四散溃逃，金斯米尔和格雷被捕并被处决。霍克赫斯特帮就这样走到了尽头。这也标志着那种官方走私模式的终结。虽然之后还出现了更多的帮派，局势也确实起起伏伏，但就我们所说的——打上引号的——黄金时代而言，这就是全部了。那么，亚历克斯，你的英雄、女主角是一个女性。有多少女性参与其中？因为确实有一些，对吧？确实有一些，但这也并非……
I think one can overstate it. I mean, Anne Bonny and Mary Read were were much more privateers than than smugglers, but they did smuggle. Bessie Catchpole. Yeah. I mean, again, there are these there these kind of notorious figures. They were often the landladies of inns. And so, for instance, during the Battle of Mudderford, which was... We've got a question about that. Yeah, Stephen Clark, a friend of the show, has asked about that.
我认为人们可能夸大了这一点。我的意思是，安妮·伯妮（Anne Bonny）和玛丽·里德（Mary Read）更多是私掠船船员，而不是走私犯，不过她们确实也走私过。贝西·卡奇波尔（Bessie Catchpole）。是的。我的意思是，同样地，历史上确实有这些声名狼藉的人物。她们通常是客栈的女老板。例如，在穆德福德战役（Battle of Mudderford）期间，那场战役……我们有一个关于这个的问题。是的，节目的好朋友斯蒂芬·克拉克（Stephen Clark）问过这件事。
Was it the last battle fought on English soil, he says? 1784. I mean, I will defer as far as the history goes, but it was certainly a battle. And, you know, the captain of the revenue ship was killed. Where was this? Mudderford is just outside of Christchurch. What's that, Hampshire? the captain of the revenue ship was killed. It was... And where was this? Mudderford is just outside of Christchurch.
他说，这难道是在英格兰本土上进行的最后一场战役吗？1784年。我的意思是，在历史细节上我可能会有所保留，但它绝对是一场战役。而且，你知道，那艘税收船的船长被杀了。这是在哪里？穆德福德就在基督城郊外。那是哪里，汉普郡吗？税收船的船长被杀了。这是……而这是在哪里？穆德福德就在基督城郊外。
Was that Hampshire? Yeah, sort of Hampshire, Dorset, I think. So yeah, and it was brutal. I mean, I think, you know, again, what it shows you is that it absolutely hadn't abated. But I guess what had happened was that the absolute hold that these organised gangs had over this part of the world really fell away in the 1750s. 1781, 100 mounted soldiers and 900 infantrymen went to deal and seized goods from the smugglers valued at £10 million.
那是汉普郡吗？是的，大概是汉普郡、多塞特郡一带，我想。所以，是的，而且这场战斗极其残暴。我的意思是，我认为，这再次向你表明，这种现象绝对没有减弱。但我想发生的变化是，这些有组织帮派对世界这一地区的绝对控制，在18世纪50年代确实衰落了。1781年，100名骑兵和900名步兵前往迪尔（Deal），查获了价值1000万英镑的走私货物。
So, I mean, it's still £10 million in today's money. And there's a guy, Tom Johnston from Limington, who during the Napoleonic Wars used to smuggle gold from Britain to France. So that's really interesting. So they're called guinea runs. And that was really, and, you know, all the way through the Napoleonic War. I mean, it's really again, if I'm I'm being sort of encouraged to write a follow up to Winchelsea. And I think there is something really fun about this idea of suddenly you had information with huge value on it.
所以，我的意思是，按今天的金钱价值算，这仍然相当于1000万英镑。还有一个叫汤姆·约翰斯顿（Tom Johnston）的来自利明顿（Limington）的人，他在拿破仑战争期间经常把黄金从英国走私到法国。所以这非常有趣。它们被称为“几尼走私”（guinea runs）。这就是当时的真实情况，而且贯穿了整个拿破仑战争。我的意思是，这再次表明，如果有人鼓励我写一本《温奇尔萨》的续集的话，我觉得突然之间掌握了拥有巨大价值的情报这种设定会非常有趣。
And the smugglers were were were viable. I mean, they felt no kind of. Napoleon tries to hire him to guide the invasion fleet, conquer England. And then if England had won, then he'd be well paid and he patriotically refused. Oh, well, that's interesting because very often the smugglers did not refuse and were very happy to, and you know, the running back and forth of spies as well. You know, it's interesting because obviously there was this constant threat from France. And I mean, the reason Winchelsea only has half a church is because you know the French just knocked the other half down and uh and and you know there were kind of raids on this area part of Rye was was French territory for for hundreds of years um it was owned by the Abbey of Fécond um so there is a real sense of again
而且这些走私者确实很有生存能力。我的意思是，他们毫无……拿破仑曾试图雇佣他来为入侵舰队引路以征服英格兰。如果英格兰战败，他就能得到丰厚的报酬，但他出于爱国主义拒绝了。哦，好吧，这很有意思，因为很多时候走私者并没有拒绝，而且非常乐意这么做，你知道的，还有间谍来来回回的活动。你知道这很有意思，因为显然当时法国一直构成威胁。我的意思是，温奇尔萨之所以只有半座教堂，就是因为法国人把另一半给砸毁了……而且你知道，这一带曾遭受过袭击，赖伊的一部分曾连续几百年来都是法国领土，它曾属于费康修道院（Abbey of Fécamp），所以确实有一种与欧洲大陆的紧密联系……关于这个……哦，继续吧，汤姆，你来问个问题。不，不，不，你问吧。我本来想说，我们收到过几个关于所谓的“走私之王”的问题。比如，我知道你对康沃尔的走私犯很不以为然，但有一个非常著名的走私犯叫约翰·卡特（John Carter），被称为“普鲁士国王”。亚历克斯，你知道他吗？是的，我知道。绝对知道。所以普鲁士国王约翰·卡特，汤姆，我的朋友杰克·斯泰因（Jack Stein）
these linkages with the continent what's about um oh go go on, Tom, I'll ask you a question. No, no, no, you go. I was about to say we had a couple of questions about so-called smuggling kings. So, for example, I know you're very down on Cornish smugglers, but there is a very famous smuggler called John Carter, the King of Prussia. Do you know about him, Alex? Yeah, I do. Absolutely. So John Carter, the King of Prussia, Tom and my friend Jack Stein was
听到我们要谈论普鲁士国王时非常高兴。而且，对不起啊杰克，跟东南部地区的走私者相比，他的规模相对较小。他以一个海湾为基地，现在那个海湾被称为普鲁士湾，或者我想是以他的名字命名为普鲁士湾。他之所以被称为“普鲁士国王”，是因为他喜欢……以他的名字命名为普鲁士湾。他被称为普鲁士国王，是因为他从小就喜欢扮演普鲁士国王。是的，人们不是说他长得像腓特烈大帝吗？真的吗？
very happy to hear that we would be talking about the King of Prussia. It was, and I'm sorry, Jack, it was relatively small scale compared to the Southeastern smugglers. He was based in a bay that is now called the Bay of Prussia, or I think it's called the Bay of Prussia after him. He was called the King of Prussia because he liked to play's called the Bay of Prussia after him. He was called the King of Prussia because he liked to play act as the King of Prussia as a child. Yeah, didn't he look like, people said he looked like Frederick the Great. Is that true?
我没听说过这个，但我确实听说过他在童年游戏里总是扮演普鲁士国王。很棒的游戏。所以，是的，他当时也是在走私白兰地、越来越多的烟草，把它们运到布里斯托尔。我们得记住交通问题。汤姆刚才说过，所有的钱其实都在伦敦。把货物从康沃尔运出哪怕一小段距离，都是极其昂贵且困难的。
I hadn't heard that, but I certainly heard that in childhood games, he would always be the King of Prussia. Great games. And so, yeah, he was, again, he was running brandy, tobacco increasingly, running it up to Bristol. Got to remember transport. Tom was saying earlier, you know, all the all the money was in London, really. And transporting stuff from Cornwall any distance at all was was incredibly expensive and difficult.
所以这始终只是一个局部的事情。但他是一个相当可爱的人物。而且，当然，杜穆里埃（de Maurier）的小说就取材于普鲁士国王的故事，他和他的家人都是卫理公会信徒，对吧？他们都是非常坚定的卫理公会信徒，还有他的兄弟……他们卷入了与1788年税收官员和英国皇家海军的大规模冲突中，他的兄弟趁机逃跑，去了纽约，最后竟然变成了一个奴隶。太离谱了，是的……我不知道这一点。他……好吧，我不知道他在技术上算不算奴隶，但他基本上是在一个种植园或农场里，和奴隶们一起干活，然后不知怎么设法回到了法国，结果被关在……这非常像《波尔达克》，非常……我的意思是，我很想写他的故事。我的意思是，
So it was only ever a localised thing. But he is a kind of lovely. And, you know, certainly de Maurier drew on the story of the King of Pr king and he and his family are all methodists aren't they they're all very key methodists and his brother they're there they have some massive fight with um the customs men in 1788 with the navy the royal navy his brother escapes goes to new york and ends up becoming a slave extraordinary yeah he's i didn't know that he's he's well i don't know whether he's technically a slave but he basically ends up on a plantation or a farm working alongside slaves and then somehow manages to get back to he gets back to france and is imprisoned in the it's very it's very poldark it's very i mean i quite want to write his story i mean the the
那种女扮男装的把戏太……说到贝西·卡奇波尔，她的丈夫是个走私犯。他死后，她就穿上他的灰色大衣，叼着烟斗，佩戴着弯刀，结果一个荷兰人嘲笑她。于是她一拳打在那个荷兰人的脸上，打掉了他的牙齿。
whole dressing up thing is so to go go back to Bessie Catchpole, her husband was a smuggler. He dies. So she dresses up in his grey coat, smokes a pipe, wears a cutlass, and a Dutchman laughs at her. And so she punches him in the face, knocks out his teeth.
这就是你对待恐跨症患者的方式。我还以为你会说“这就是你对待荷兰人的方式”呢。不，我绝不会那样说，你知道我非常喜欢荷兰人……我确信绝大多数荷兰人不会仅仅因为一个女人佩戴弯刀、叼着烟斗就嘲笑她……但那种行为——这又回到了罗宾汉的故事上——作为一个著名的走私犯，你显然得建立一个个人招牌，无论你是看起来像腓特烈大帝，还是作为一个女性佩戴着弯刀，诸如此类。但那只是死后才有的。我的意思是，你不需要在生前就刻意打造什么招牌。这大概让我们回到了这样一种观念：随着18世纪迈入19世纪，走私者开始成为文学虚构、浪漫主义、神话传说等的素材，
And that's how you treat transphobes. I thought you could say that's how you treat Dutchmen. No i'd never say that you know i love the dutch um i'm sure most dutch wouldn't laugh at a woman just because she wore a cutlass and smoked a pipe um but there's the the kind of that and that's going back to the robin hood thing that you as a famous smuggler you obviously have to have a brand whether you are looking like frederick the great or you know wearing a cutlass if you're a woman or whatever but only posthumously i mean these are these are i mean you don't have to have a brand, whether you are looking like Frederick the Great or, you know, wearing a cutlass if you're a woman or whatever. Yeah, but only posthumously. I mean, you don't have to have a brand at the time. And that presumably takes us back to the idea that, you know, smugglers, as the 18th century turns into the 19th century, so it starts to become grist for the mill of literary fiction
诸如此类。是的，绝对是这样。而且，同样地，考虑到这些书出版的时期，其中蕴含着一种真正的怀旧情绪。如果你读《月亮船》（Moonfleet）——出版于1899年，你知道，它正处于现代主义的边缘、世纪之末——你会发现一种强烈的心态：回溯到一个这样的时代：当地的乡绅是一个权力通的人物，同时还有那些做好事的、高尚的恶棍……你知道吗？我很抱歉又要挑你这份书单的毛病，《月亮船》的结尾真的是最不同寻常的结局之一——我的意思是，又是剧透警告——他们进了监狱，然后时间突然快进了几十年，那种感觉
and romance and myth and so on. Yes, absolutely. And, you know, again, thinking about when these books were published, you know, there is a real nostalgia in there. You know, if you read Moonfleet, so published 1899, you know, it's kind of just on the cusp of modernism, end of the century, a real sense of looking back at a time when, you know, the local squire was this sort of all-powerful figure and and and there were these kind of noble uh uh ruffians who who were were doing good things it's a do you know what i i wanted i'm sorry to have another go at your list but it really the end of moon fleet is one of the most extraordinary i mean again spoiler alert but they they they go to jail uh and then it's suddenly you sort of cycle for decades and it's
绝对美妙。我的意思是，这真的有一种LP·哈特利（L. P. Hartley）式的对黄金时代的怀念。这是一部非常、
absolutely beautiful. I mean, it really is a sort of LP Hartley-esque nostalgia for, for, for a, for a golden age. It's, it's a beautiful,
非常美丽的小说。所以，亚历克斯，我们快结束了，但我想问一个关于现在的问题。因为过去十年——也许是二十年——发生变化的一点是，我们开始看到走私卷土重来，而现在是人口走私，或者是毒品，
beautiful novel. So Alex, we're coming to the end now, but just a question about the present, because one of the things that's changed, I guess, over the past decade maybe two decades is that we're starting to see smuggling happen again and now it's it's people smuggling or drugs
我猜是毒品？——或者是毒品，是的，或者毒品。而且其中没有任何浪漫色彩，我的意思是，它们有着一种黑暗的名声。你认为这开始反过来影响人们现在如何看待18世纪了吗？老实说，我不知道人们是否会将两者联系起来，但我绝对完全赞同这种看法。你知道，我多么希望人们能通过了解现状来对18世纪有一个更好、更真实的认识。你不可能像我们这样住在苏塞克斯郡却对正在发生的贩运人口贸易一无所知。你知道，我的朋友约翰就住在罗瑟河畔，就在赖伊的河口，前几天就有人从水里爬出来，直接进了他的花园。我对此有第一手的切身体会，因为自从我搬到这里以来，
i suppose or drugs yes or drugs uh and and there's nothing really romantic about any of them i mean they have they have a kind of dark reputation And do you think that that is starting to affect retrospectively how people see the 18th century now? I don't know that people make the linkage, if I'm honest with you, but I certainly fully subscribe to that. You know, I would love to think that people would get a better and truer portrait of the 18th century by understanding how things are now. You can't live where we live in Sussex here and not be aware of the trade in people that goes on. You know, my friend John lives just on the River Rother, right at its mouth in Rye, and he had somebody in his garden just coming out of the waters just the other day. I see this firsthand because really since I moved down here,
我意识到不断有人抵达，我想为此做点什么。有一个绝佳的慈善机构叫“肯特善良行动”（Kent Kindness）。我们所做的事情之一，就是教导那些抵达这里的无人陪伴的未成年人。我们教他们基础的英语。英语，是的。好吧，相信我，阿富汗人受到了热烈的欢迎，因为他们为当地的板球队效力，他们是极好的、极好的板球运动员。但是，你知道，教他们如何开设银行账户，如何在镇上问路，基础的英语，所有这些诸如此类的事情。所以最迷人的是每周看到他们——就像我所做的那样——你能真正感受到他们来自哪里，感受到人口贩运的起起伏伏，以及他们所经历的经历，这些经历非常不同。所以你会有大概三条他们会选择的路线。
I recognised that there were people arriving and I wanted to do something about it. And there's a wonderful charity called Kent Kindness. And we, so what we do is we teach the unaccompanied minors who arrive. We teach them basic kind of, you know, English, English. Yes. Well, believe me, the Afghans have been made very welcome because they've they've been turned out, turning out for the local cricket teams. They're wonderful, wonderful cricketers. But, you know, teaching them how to open a bank account, how to ask for directions in town, you know, basic English, all of this sort of stuff. So the thing that's so fascinating is seeing them every week, as I do, you get a real sense of where they're coming from, of the kind of ebbs and flows of trafficking and of the experiences they've had, which are very different. So you've got you've got kind of three routes that they take. You know, at one point, it was very much coming up from
你知道，在某个时期，情况主要是从厄立特里亚、南苏丹、埃塞俄比亚北上，也就是说，我可以说90%抵达这里的孩子都来自非洲。当然，那是一艘来自利比亚的船。据那些孩子们告诉我，利比亚简直就是一个人间炼狱。那里运作的帮派……顺便说一句，这些帮派实际上是非常迷人的一张网络，你知道，那里有大量的俄罗斯和东欧黑手党操盘手。当地总会有接应的人。所以在苏丹会有一个充当第一站的人，关系网极其庞大，组织极其严密，在管理从利比亚运送到西西里岛甚至希腊、但主要是意大利的过程中表现得非常老练，然后他们再穿过欧洲前往加来。
Eritrea, South Sudan, Ethiopia, you know, that it was it was I would say 90% of the kids that arrived here were from Africa. And that, of course, is a boat from Libya. Libya, from what I hear from the kids, is an absolute hellhole. The gangs that operate there. And by the way, these gangs, really like fascinating network of, you know, there's a lot of Russian and Eastern European mafia operators here. You know, there will always be a local player. So there will be somebody in Sudan who is the kind of first port of call, incredibly networked, incredibly well organised, very, very sophisticated in terms of how it's all managed over to Sicily or to Greece even, but mainly to Italy from Libya, and then making their way up through Europe to Calais.
其他的路线是土耳其和希腊，通常是坐货车。所以这是通过货车完成的，然后同样前往加来，或者通过白俄罗斯，我猜还有保加利亚、罗马尼亚。那种情况可能稍微少一点。目前，我想说的是，在我接触到的人当中，同样有90%来自库尔德斯坦。所以他们主要还是通过土耳其和希腊那条路线过来的。而且，你知道，他们往往是……首先，他们的受教育程度相对较高。他们到达这里时有时能说一口相当不错的英语。他们不得不向这些走私帮派支付高达2.5万英镑的费用。
The other routes, Turkey and Greece, often in lorries. So that's done in lorries and then again to Calais, or through Belarus and, guess Bulgaria, Romania. That's maybe slightly less. At the moment, I would say, again, 90% is from Kurdistan of the people that I'm seeing. So they will have come through that Turkey and Greece route mainly. And, you know, they are they tend to be, you know, firstly from relatively better educated. They sometimes speak quite good English when they arrive here. They have to pay up to twenty five thousand pounds to to these smuggling gangs
其他路线，土耳其和希腊，通常乘坐卡车。所以这是通过卡车完成的，然后再去加来，或者通过白俄罗斯，猜猜还有保加利亚、罗马尼亚。那个可能稍微少一点。目前，我想说，我见过的这些人中，依然有90%来自库尔德斯坦。所以他们主要还是通过土耳其和希腊那条路线来的。而且，你知道，他们往往，你知道的，首先受过相对较好的教育。他们到达这里时有时英语说得相当好。他们必须向这些走私团伙支付高达两万五千英镑的费用。
to get here. They come over in inflatable dinghies. Um, so literally I, I, you know, the sort of thing that my kids would have on the pond, um, it's that sort of thing. And the reason they do that is because they're not detectable on radar. Um, so, uh, it is a, it is a, you know, absolutely monstrous thing. It is, uh, it is, you know, I always think of that, that golden rule thing of, uh, uh, the Kantian imperative of, you know, treating people as an end in themselves rather than a means. And these are people who just see others as means. There are operators, of course, in the UK. One of the other things that I've done is a project called Refugee Tales, which was set up by the poet David Hurd.
来到这里。他们乘充气橡皮艇横渡。嗯，字面上讲，我，我，你知道的，就像我孩子们在池塘里玩的的那种，嗯，就是那种。他们这么做的原因是因为雷达探测不到。嗯，所以，呃，这是一个，这是一个，你知道的，绝对极其骇人听闻的事情。这，呃，这，你知道的，我总是想起那个黄金法则，呃，康德的绝对命令，你知道的，把人当作目的本身，而不是手段。而这些人只是把其他人当作手段。当然，英国也有蛇头。我做过的另一件事是一个叫做“难民故事”的项目，是由诗人大卫·赫德发起 的。
And what he did, and it's with the Gatwick Refugee Detainees Charity as well, they pair you with a refugee as a writer and get you to tell their story. So it's brilliant. Ali Smith has done it. Our friend Kamala Shamsi has done it. Abdul Razak Gurner has done it. And I was paired with a boy from, I won't say which country because I didn't say which country in the story because he was really in major danger.
他的做法是——这也是与盖特威克难民被拘留者慈善机构合作进行的——他们把你和一个难民作家配对，让你去讲述他们的故事。所以这真的很棒。阿里·史密斯做过。我们的朋友卡米拉·沙姆西做过。阿卜杜勒-拉扎克·古尔纳也做过。我和一个来自某国的男孩配对了，我不会说具体哪个国家，因为我在故事里也没有说具体哪个国家，因为他真的处于极度危险之中。
His brother was killed by the state. And and his story of interacting with the with the smuggling gangs, he actually ended up it was a kind of charitable organisation that got him to the UK because he was absolutely about to be killed. But then he was approached by a gang in London who said, oh, by the way, it's so much better in France, you'll get, you know, you'll get £40,000 a year and everyone's going to look after you, you've got to go to France. He paid them a load of money, got to France, was sent back, was arrested. Just absolutely horrifying situation. So the question is that if you think of Kent or Sussex or, you know, I mean, that's the definition of rural England, calm, peaceful. And that's why there's the sense of shock in reading your book and realising that these were scenes of unbelievable brutality, kind of
他的兄弟被国家杀害了。他与走私团伙接触的故事——他其实最终是一个慈善组织把他带到了英国，因为他当时绝对面临着被杀的危险。但随后他在伦敦被一个团伙接近，对方说，哦，顺便说一句，法国好得多，你会拿到，你知道的，每年4万英镑，每个人都会照顾你，你必须去法国。他付给他们一大笔钱，到了法国，被遣返回国，被捕了。简直是绝对令人毛骨悚然的情况。所以问题是，如果你想到肯特郡或苏塞克斯，或者，你知道的，我的意思是，那是英格兰乡村的定义，平静，祥和。这就是为什么读你的书会感到震惊，并意识到这些曾是难以置信的残暴场景，某种
paramilitary activity in the 18th century. But now those same kind of pressures perhaps are starting to materialise along the beaches. Well, we just had in Hastings the other day, the lifeboats were trying to go out and rescue a refugee boat and a group of locals uh physically stopped them from going out uh there is a there is a violence down here that is not um that is not there on the postcards but you go to particularly some of the kind of towns uh as you go along the kent coast um and it's a it it's a dark dark place have you read it all the devils are here hey oh that's a novel you should novel a book you read All the Devils Are Here? No. Oh, that's a novel you should read. A novel, a book you should read.
18世纪的准军事活动。但现在同样的那种压力也许开始在海滩边显现出来了。嗯，我们前几天在黑斯廷斯刚遇到过，救生艇当时正试图出海去救援一艘难民船，而一群当地人呃物理上阻止他们出海呃这里有一种暴力，是明信片上所没有的呃，但你去到一些特定的城镇，呃，当你沿著肯特海岸前行时，呃，这是一个阴暗、阴暗的地方。你看过《所有的恶魔都在这里》吗？哎，哦，那是一部小说，你应该读小说...你看过《所有的恶魔都在这里》吗？没有。哦，那是一部你应该读的小说。小说，一本你应该读的书。
Brilliant kind of memoir of the Kent coast. One last question before we kind of wrap this up. I mean, you're talking about smuggling people. What about smuggling things? I mean, drugs must get into Britain somehow, and there must be other things that are smuggled in. Or has smuggling by sea of goods, as opposed to people, has that kind of died a death now?
关于肯特海岸的精彩回忆录。在我们结束之前最后一个问题。我的意思是，你在谈论走私人口。走私物品呢？我的意思是，毒品一定是通过某种方式进入英国的，而且一定有其他东西被走私进来。或者说，通过海路走私货物（而不是人口），现在已经基本上绝迹了吗？
It has largely died a death, and that's because smuggling is mainly done in lorries now. So if you look at where particularly drugs, I mean, I'm trying to think about what other smuggling there might be, but really, you know, it does tend to be drugs. Drugs are lorries and, you know. We is it does tend to be drugs, drugs and lorries. And, you know, it's guns. Yeah, I guess weapons and guns. You know, not not my area of expertise. But, you know, of course, it clearly still happens. And again, it's one of those things where
它基本上已经绝迹了，那是因为现在走私主要是通过卡车进行的。所以如果你看看毒品主要在哪里，我的意思是，我在努力想可能还有什么其他走私，但真的，你知道的，往往还是毒品。毒品都是靠卡车，而且，你知道的。我们是，确实往往是毒品，毒品和卡车。而且，你知道的，是枪支。对，我猜是武器和枪支。你知道的，这不是我的专业领域。但是，你知道的，当然，这显然仍在发生。而且再次，这是那种
the kind of darker side of I mean, you know, the whole kind of tours of Pablo Escobar's home and all this. I mean, I think that's just, again this is this is sickening, sickening and brutal stuff. But doesn't that answer Tom's question in perhaps not a very cheery way? Because Tom was asking, you know, does our awareness of people smuggling now change our view of the 18th century? And isn't the answer to that? Actually, it won't change our view of the 18th century because we still romanticize criminals now i mean maybe we don't romanticize people smugglers but the whole narcos pablo escobar the wire you know there are there are endless sort of tv programs and things where we peeky blinders where we we we completely glamorize and romanticize no and my not and my novel does it too you know i i'm i'm absolutely part of the problem here. And I
我指的是帕布罗·埃斯科巴之家的各种游览之类的更黑暗的一面。我的意思是，我认为这再次，这是令人作呕、令人作呕和残忍的东西。但这难道不是以一种也许不太愉快的方式回答了汤姆的问题吗？因为汤姆刚才问，我们对人口走私的认识现在是否改变了我们对18世纪的看法？难道答案不应该是：实际上，这不会改变我们对18世纪的看法，因为我们现在仍然在浪漫化罪犯？我的意思是，也许我们没有浪漫化人口蛇头，但整个毒枭、巴勃罗·埃斯科巴、《火线》，你知道的，有没完没了的电视节目和诸如此类的东西，比如《浴血黑帮》，我们完全美化和浪漫化了——不，我的，我的小说也这样，你知道的，我，我绝对是问题的一部分。我
recognise that. But I guess, you know, I feel like on a history podcast, one wants to get at the truth. And I feel like it's important to recognise that there is a kind of a public imagination, a kind of willful miscasting of this historical period. well your novel in no way i mean you know you can't read it and not feel that the smugglers were horrible i mean they're spectacularly horrible um and it's a brilliant book fabulous novel um as i say it's uh daphne de moria across with quentin tarantino except it's not daphne de moria is it because she wrote about cornwall and i've made it very clear cornwall forget it yeah so Alex we've lost all our Cornish listeners yeah thanks so much guys it's it's been a brilliant myth-busting exercise uh and if you love a good novel Winter Sea
意识到了这一点。但我想，你知道的，我觉得在一个历史播客中，人们想要触及真相。我觉得重要的是要认识到，存在着一种公众的想象力，一种对这一历史时期的蓄意曲解。嗯，你的小说绝没有——我的意思是，你读了不可能不觉得那些走私犯很可怕——我的意思是，他们极其可怕，嗯，这是一本好书，棒极了的小说，正如我所说，它是达夫妮·杜穆里埃遇上昆汀·塔伦蒂诺，不过又不是达夫妮·杜穆里埃，对吧？因为她写的是康沃尔，而我已经把话说得很清楚了，康沃尔，忘掉它吧。是的，所以亚历克斯，我们失去了所有的康沃尔听众，是的，非常感谢大家，这是一次精彩的打破迷信的活动，呃，如果你喜欢一本好小说《冬海》
go and get it brilliant so we will see you all of you next week for what delights have we got in store Tom uh we got Valentine's Day we We do. We do have Valentine's Day. And we've got American Crusades. America's Holy Wars. And beyond that, we are thinking about the top 10 disastrous parties, aren't we? We are. Yes, we are. Not inspired by anything in the news, of course.
去买吧，太棒了。所以我们下周会和大家见面，看看汤姆，我们准备了什么好东西？我们有情人节。我们确实有。我们确实有情人节。我们还有美国的十字军东征。美国的圣战。除此之外，我们在考虑十大灾难派对，对吧？是的，我们是的。当然，这绝对不是受任何新闻启发而来的。
So thank you again to Alex, and we'll see you all next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. If you wake up midnight and hear a horse's feet. I'm going to do that again. No! The listeners want to hear that. I'll do it again.
所以再次感谢亚历克斯，我们下次再见。再见。再见。如果你在午夜醒来，听到马蹄声……我得再来一次。不！听众们想听那个。我再来一次。
Tom. So if you're going to laugh, mute yourself. Because otherwise I won't be able to do it. If you wake up midnight. Sorry. Sorry, Alex. Tom, I'm not even going to look at you. If you wake at midnight and hear a horse...
汤姆。所以如果你要笑，把自己静音。否则我就没法做了。如果你在午夜醒来……抱歉。抱歉，亚历克斯。汤姆，我甚至不看你了。如果你在午夜醒来，听到马……
We will get there, Alex, I promise. This is fine. I should say, I have an interview with BBC Scotland at 3.40. OK, I'm going to... OK, press is on. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
我们能做到的，亚历克斯，我保证。这很好。我应该说，我在3点40分有一个BBC苏格兰的采访。好的，我要……好，录音中。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。想要获取独家单集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝娱乐圈八卦的固定去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想要无广告收听、独家单集以及优先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。